welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is David gogins
David Goggins is a retired Navy SEAL who
served in Iraq and Afghanistan he's also
a highly accomplished ultramarathon
runner for those of you that don't know
ultramarathons are distances longer than
26 mil and in David's case often longer
than 200 mil for his achievements in
athletics he has been inducted into the
International Sports Hall of Fame he
also held a Guinness world record for
the most pull-ups completed in 24 hours
I should mention that Not only was David
a decorated Navy SEAL but he also
graduated from Army Ranger school David
is also a highly successful writer
having authored two books the first
entitled can't hurt me and the second
entitled never finished both of which
are best sellers David's books cover
many topics including his
autobiographical description of what can
only be described as an incredibly
challenging child and young adulthood
his home was abusive his school
environment was abusive he essentially
had no positive resources directed his
way and in his 20s he found himself to
be obese that is more than 300 PBS
working a job he despised for minimal
pay and it was at that point that David
began an inner dialog that forced him to
explore the demons born out of his
childhood but also the position that he
found himself in as a young man and then
began the journey to navigate that
dialogue and transform himself into the
Navy SEAL the ultramarathon runner the
bestselling author and the
extraordinarily positive and influential
man that he is today as some of you may
know David has done various public
lectures he's a familiar face online
because there are so many clips of him
on YouTube and he has done podcast
before however I'm certain that you'll
find today's discussion to be very
different than previous podcast that
David has been featured on the reason is
that of course we get into his
accomplishments we talk about the
mindset that allowed him to achieve
those things but today David really lets
us under the hood he lets us into the
form of inner dialogue that he has to
embrace indeed that he has to Grapple
with on a daily basis sometimes multiple
times throughout the day and night in
order to impose the sort of
self-discipline that he is so well known
for we also get into some of the
scientific mechanisms underlying
willpower and we talk about David's
current Endeavors that include for
instance his own exploration of science
and medicine for which he has become an
intense scholar and practitioner I
should mention that multiple times
throughout today's discussion you will
hear curse words now David and I both
acknowledge that cursing isn't for
everybody and that cursing itself is
different than than cursing at somebody
nonetheless we do realize that many
people parents perhaps especially might
not want to hear cursing if you don't
want to hear cursing well then this
podcast episode is probably not for you
however if you are comfortable with
cursing or if you can tolerate it I
assure you today's discussion is highly
worthwhile before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my design
desire and effort to bring zero cost to
Consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Maui neui
venison Maui Nei venison is the most
nutrient-dense and delicious red meat
available I've spoken before on this
podcast and there's General consensus
that most people should strive to
consume approximately one gram of
protein per pound of body weight now
when one strives to do that it's
important to maximize imiz the quality
of that protein intake to the calorie
ratio because you don't want to consume
an excess of calories when trying to get
that 1 gram of protein per pound of body
weight Maui Nei venison has an extremely
high quality protein to calorie ratio so
it makes getting that one gram of
protein per pound of body weight
extremely easy it's also delicious
personally I like the ground venison I
also like the venison steaks and then
for convenience when I'm on the road I
like the jerky the jerky is a very high
protein to calorie ratio so it has as
much as 10 grams of protein per jerky
stick and it has something like only
like 55 calories so again making it very
easy to get enough protein without
consuming excess calories if you would
like to try Maui neui venison you can go
to mauii venison
docomond to get 20% off your first order
again that's Maui venison
docomo to get 20% off today's episode is
also brought To Us by Aeropress aress is
similar to a French press for making
coffee but is in fact a much better way
to make coffee I first learned about
Aeropress well over 10 years ago and
I've been using one ever since Aeropress
was developed by Allan Adler who was an
engineer at Stanford and I knew of Allen
because he had also built the so-called
aobi frisbee which I believe at one time
perhaps still now held the Guinness Book
of World Records for furthest thrown
object and I used to see Allan believe
it or not at parks around paloalto
testing out different aobi frisbee so he
was sort of famous in our community for
developing these different Feats of
engineering that turned into commercial
products now I love coffee I'm somebody
that drinks coffee nearly every day
usually about 90 to 120 minutes after I
wake up in the morning although not
always sometimes if I'm going to
exercise I'll drink coffee first thing
in the morning but I love love love
coffee and what I've personally found is
that by using the Arrow Press I can make
the best possible tasting cup of coffee
I don't know what exactly it is in the
arero press that allows the same beans
to be prepared into a cup of coffee that
tastes that much better as compared to
any other form of Brewing that coffee
even the traditional French press the AO
press is extremely easy to use and it's
extremely compact in fact I take it with
me whenever I travel and I use it on the
road in hotels even on planes I'll just
ask for some hot water and I'll Brew my
coffee or tea right there on the plane
if you'd like to try Aeropress you can
go to arero press.com huberman that's a
r o p
s.com huberman to get 20% off any
Aeropress coffee maker Aeropress ships
anywhere in the USA Canada and over 60
other countries around the world again
that's Aero press.com huberman to get
20% off today's episode is also brought
To Us by eight sleep eight sleep makes
Smart mattress covers with cooling
Heating and sleep tracking capacity I've
spoken many times before in this podcast
about the fact that sleep is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance now a key
component of getting a great night's
sleep is that in order to fall and stay
deeply asleep your body temperature
actually has to drop by about 1 to 3°
and in order to wake up feeling
refreshed and energized your body
temperature actually has to increase by
about 1 to 3° one of the best ways to
make sure that those temperature changes
occur at the appropriate times at the
beginning and throughout and at the end
of your night when you wake up is to
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment and that's what eight sleep
allows you to do it allows you to
program the temperature of your mattress
and sleeping environment such that you
fall and stay deeply asleep easily and
wake wake up each morning feeling
incredibly refreshed and energized I've
been sleeping on an eight sleep mattress
cover for almost 3 years now and it has
dramatically improve the quality of my
sleep if you'd like to try eightsleep
you can go to 8sleep.com
huberman to get $150 off their pod three
mattress cover eight sleep currently
ships in the USA Canada UK select
countries in the EU and Australia again
that's 8sleep.com
huberman and now for my discussion with
David gogin David gogin welcome my man
good to see you again man great to see
you it was late 2016 early 2017 I
believe when you were in my lab at
Stanford yes sir uh we did a little work
later that that day down in San Jose and
gosh uh see you everywhere but it's not
enough so great to have you here thanks
for having me on brother yeah you embody
discipline and doing hard things right I
think just start right off with let's
just go there the Bold truth but right
before we went hot mics right we were
talking about learning right right now
you're spending some time learning and
doing things that I think most people
probably don't typically associate David
goggin with right why don't you tell us
about that well most people just look at
me as the guy that runs and yells as
he's running and that's uh while I do
that you know to motivate people but
people don't understand that my day is
broken up into segments I work out I eat
I sleep but I spend most of my time
studying so like I'm in the medical
world I'm a you know paramedic in uh in
Canada but I spent a lot of my time
trying to Nuke every single thing about
it because I'm not trying to just be a
paramedic learn about veins and arteries
and how the heart pumps and stuff like
that I'm trying to learn to the point
where I can save someone's life and even
though paramics are doing that all over
the world I'm trying to be that
paramedic that can really dissect
exactly what's going on and figure out
you know what medication goes where just
trying to you know just trying to learn
you know the the algorithm of what's
going on man so I spent a lot of time
with it I love the word algorithm
because when I teach biology or try and
learn anything that's related to biology
and especially the human body right I
need to know the nouns yep but it's the
verbs that matter and that's really what
you're talking about like like just
saying that that sits there that brain
part there doesn't tell you how it all
works together no so what does your
process for studying look like like if
we dropped a
a uh camera in the room but a microphone
into that into your inner dialogue right
gosh wouldn't wouldn't we all love that
but if we dropped a microphone into your
inner dialogue are you waking up looking
at the books and going yeah fresh day
let's learn or is some of the same
resistance that you've talked about
coming up around physical y work is that
coming up from time to time you know
what I was nervous at first I'm gon keep
the mother I'm Gonna Keep It Real I'm G
keep it real so
I'm not a real smart guy and what I mean
by that is I was born with ADD ADHD all
like my brain cannot retain information
I'm not some genetic freak when it comes
to running when it comes to lifting
weights I'm I am absolutely the bottom
of the barrel and people will never
believe me and they can just you know
whatever believe what you want to
believe so when you ask me this question
about what the studying look like for
me I have to go over the same page
over and over and over and over again
while Jennifer can look at that page
while she's you know quizzing me she'll
learn it right then as she's she didn't
know anything about it she will quiz
herself or quiz me and learn it as she's
quizzing me it's the most frustrating
thing in the world how my brain works so
what I so what I do is I literally sit
there with a pen and paper and I have my
books and I go through and have to write
everything down every single day I will
study the same page until it's
photographic memory from writing the
same thing down and then from there I'll
go back through and relearn again so
I'll learn the bulk of it but then I'll
go through and learn the small things
within that so if it's a medication I'll
learn what the medication does I'll
first I'll learn how to even say the
medication because these medications
aren't like you know like alter all no
it's it's it's very big words so I'll go
through learn how to say the name then
I'll go through learn what the dose is
then I'll go through and this is like
every single day so not like oh I got it
let's just go through no nothing is I
got it every single thing that's so I I
I can't wait to get in this conversation
because everything I do in life it sucks
everything I do in life it sucks that's
why when I was 300 lbs and 20 4 years
old it was like it had some big
epiphany of let's just go be a Navy SEAL
and let's lose some weight no I knew my
entire life was going to be a struggle
which is why I just ignored it and I
said I'm not even trying to jump off
into this and learn how to read how
to write how to memorize how to become
something I am not but through that
process something happened to me and I
realized that's this is why I feel sorry
for no one in this podcast they're going
to really not like me because people are
going to think that I am maybe lying or
maybe fibbing or exaggerating no I am
literally I was the lowest form on Earth
no Talent no ability to learn and I
literally know what it is to be rock
bottom and to build that up so that
question about learning it's the pain in
my ass and I don't have to do it it's
the thing about it I'm 49 years old and
am a
multi-millionaire I don't have to do
anything so all I thought about when I
was growing up is man I can't wait till
one day get to the point where I no
longer have to do this stuff but what
happen I got older it became a way of
living so how I do every day is how I do
every day it's a it's a discipline it's
a regimen it's a it's a it was a choice
I made made and the choice I made was
what are you willing to sacrifice and
what are you willing to give up to find
every bit of who you are as a human
being and I was willing to give up
everything to do that so studying is no
joke I love that you're studying I
recall a few years ago I heard uh some
interview or podcast with you and you
just threw out like I don't know what
I'll do next maybe I'll be a scientist
and I and I went yeah I was like cuz I
knew cuz I know you
and I see your work out there but we'
met before that if you decided that you
were going to do it right and learning
medicine which is what you're doing
right learning human physiology is so
detailed and people uh out there have to
understand when you look at a textbook
and you see the the veins and the
capillaries different colors in the when
the body's open they're not different
colors they're not right so I mean some
things are have different color contrast
but it's not like it's all labeled when
you pop it open exactly and so so the
process of writing things down by hand
is important for you do you go so you go
back and read those notes do you think
about that stuff on your runs too are
you segmenting your day like when you're
done studying are you heading out for a
run and thinking about other things or
are you still rehearsing the material in
your head so when I write it down I
write it down and I'm able to I'm
actually looking down at this table
right now because I'm back to write so
I'm actually there right now as I'm
speaking to you I write it down in a way
that I'm memorizing page
69 so I'm writing it down so then
writing it down and that page sync
together in my brain so I'm looking at
the book in my brain right now so like
that's just how it works for me and I
have to do it over and over again so
that page is stuck in my mind so I'm
literally flipping through pages as I'm
taking these tests and I'm taking these
National tests to become a paramedic or
become a advanced EMT or whatever I'm
literally as I'm taking Tak that test
I'm going through and I'm
like and I'm flipping pages in my head
of where that page was and how I do that
is just from how I how I write it and
how it's on the page when I run I can't
recall any of
it I cannot I cannot bring any of that
because I'm running how my mind is wired
now is that everything I do is what I do
because the focus it takes for me to
like right now I'm running I'm not like
a great Runner I'm not like injury-free
so like my first 20 minutes of the run
I'm limping I'm literally limping
because I've had several knee surgeries
and my body was twisted and so now it's
untwisting so people look at me oh looks
like he's limp you know like limping
when he runs I am limping when I run my
body's jacked up so I'm focusing on how
to get the best out of a broken body so
everything I do is a to AO focus on what
I'm doing at that at that point in my
life so it seems like you've really
trained away or somehow gotten away from
the add that you mentioned because what
you described it's like a deep trench
like a v-shaped trench I'm imagine like
there's a ball bearing it's like and it
can only go forward in that trench right
or back and it goes forward it's not
like sliding around at the like concave
at the bottom like a tension so it's
like you trained that up is there a
similar feeling when you're in the full
focus of running versus full focus of
studying is it kind of feel like oh yeah
that's the same Groove but different
thing or is it just completely different
world it's a completely different world
complet like it's just both of them for
me is is suffering but suffering a whole
different way like when I was going
through school I'll never forget I think
I was in third grade and back then you
know ADD ADHD wasn't like you know
here's this medicine or here's this
thing they want to put you in a special
school so for me I was so far behind in
learning that their big thing was let's
just put him in a special school because
he'll never
learn and through that process of like I
don't want to be in a special school I
don't want to be treated any differently
it really like I never took medication
I've never taken medication for this
that's why right now you see me looking
right in your eyes what the hell is is
you know is you been saying right now
and that's why I don't feel bad for
people who have ADHD who have learn
disabilities and some are impossible
because you just can't but a lot of them
you can and but people don't want to go
through the process of
focus of teaching yourself how to truly
Focus this is where my message gets lost
it gets lost because I may say you know
MF or F where you know I may be because
that's the passion that comes out of me
because that's it takes everything for
me to learn a
sentence so when I speak about David
Goggins I can't speak about David
Goggins in a way that's just calm and
cool because when I wake up I know the
journey that takes for me to find my
greatness and it's hard every nothing is
easy nothing just like oh I wake up and
I just do this or I do that or it just
know I watch people every day go through
life and it's so easy for me to be where
I'm at today it's takes every bit of me
so when I speak about it and as I get
going here you'll start seeing me the
temple will rise the passion will come
out because I'm back there I'm doing
what I do every day to become a human
being and so nothing is easy like
running is running it sucks but you have
a choice to make do you want to sit down
and go back to that guy you once were no
so this is what it takes this it it
takes that misunderstanding of people
and they'll never get it because they
were never David Goggins so that is what
it takes for me to do what I do it may
take you something differently so for me
everything has to be in the studying
everything has to be into this
everything has to be in everywhere I am
has to be there me Focus where I am
that's why you're my second podcast I've
done since Rogan since the book came out
I don't have time for that because
if I want to be great I'm not trying to
maximize money or maximize people
knowing me I do these things because
maybe someone out there will understand
me and get it and say I can grow from
this guy and others just won't sounds
like friction is something you're very
familiar with I just this a word just I
feel like it's like cast above us right
now in bold face highlighted underline
letters it's just like isoss friction
like you're you're up in the morning and
I imagine David Goggins going to the
coffee maker stretching out good morning
sunshine and you're telling me from
eyelids open there's friction yes and
that is the thing that people don't they
don't get the biggest
misunderstanding about David gaggin of
all time it's like whether you believe
in God or not I
do he put this lab rat which is me on
this planet and said let me see
what a beat up abused kid who has who
can barely learn barely learn who has a
twisted body messed up messed up
genetics sickle cell this and that let
me give him everything that pretty much
disqualifies you from the military but
back then it wasn't as and let's put him
in this and see what comes out of it so
to do that friction you don't wake up in
the morning time and go to the coffee
maker matter of fact sometimes you don't
even sleep what it requires is when I'm
at 2 o'clock in the it's 2 o'clock in
the morning and my brain is thinking
about a drug and I got to get up
and look in my book to see if that drug
is how I remember it and this is every
day of my life that's why when I
train a fighter or I train some I'm like
you have no idea how great you
really are because you are using such
minimal minimal of what you have and if
people can learn to
focus this is what's possible while it
may not be pretty like people want to do
a documentary on me I go
no I want you to do documentary on me
because I will have normal everyday
people picking me apart on his life is
miserable who wants to live like that he
looks it's crazy how he someone like
he's sick he's
psychotic the most frustrating thing in
the world for me is when normal people
judge a man like myself on what it
really takes to
extract greatness from nothing it's
takes every bit of who you are if you
choose that route if you don't Merry
Christmas do what you got to do but yeah
all these things for me like like I told
you I'm gonna keep it real I I'm not
coming here to talk about like you know
perform without purpose because I go
through when I write these books I go
through I try to dumb down David
gas how can I give normal people and I'm
normal
but I found something that most don't
want to find how can I speak to people
and give them something from this crazy
psychotic brain that I've developed how
can I give him that so I sit down with
Jennifer for years and write down
perform without purpose callous your
mind armor your mind the cookie jar the
accountability miror that people
can use in their lives no no I'm
glad it helps you but the barbaric life
that I live that you have to live the
almost Obsession that you must have to
be great you can't put that in the
book bro you can't put in a book
you can't you can't write about it has
to be experienced it has to be
experienced and you can't even after you
experience it to write it in the book it
would seem like he need to be locked up
this too gory it's too gory doesn't make
sense for a guy that everything thing
every second of the day he is trying to
extract more from
something he's constantly think he's
constantly constantly disciplined never
going off the path whatever is injured
on him he figures away it's a
conqueror's
mindset and very few people if
any can really understand what that is
like a I'm almost 50 and I've been this
way for almost 30 years years like what
you do for fun you you never like like
these questions I don't I don't get them
I don't understand them I don't so yeah
I get asked that sometimes what are you
for fun I start listing off all the
stuff like podcast and reading working
out but so some of that resonates but I
think what's
so truly unusual about what you're
describing your
process is that you know from go it's
hard Y and I have to ask was being 300
pound having ENT I'm using the words
you've described you've said it before
you had a tendency at one point in your
life early on tell lies try and get
people's approval my ass off crazy
haircuts attention seeking and and yet
all of that triggered
something that now is you know is
extraordinary right do you think those
hardships were necessary to flip the S
switch I don't know if they were
necessary but it was something that made
me
feel I didn't feel
good it was
easy the brain that I was given as a
child it was easy to go home and think
about what how do I want to be a freak
today how do I want to show up to school
today and be a freak it didn't require
me going home and open a book up saying
it's going to take me all year to learn
this page so instead of learning
that page I learned how to become a
character and maybe that character that
I created that 300 pound insecure guy
that used to fake fake it to make it
type of guy you know let me uh become
your friend let me lie to you until you
like me type of
guy when when you have any kind of any
manhood Womanhood a human being a soul a
spirit any I I had no I I must had just
this much pride cuz that's exactly what
opened the door for me cuz every day you
were a character every day you were a
clown every day you open that Spanish
book or that science book or English
book and you like you looked at it was
like it looked like a foreign
language and you're saying where do I
start where do I start and obviously it
was necessary the more I talk about it
it was necessary because what happened
is I became
haunted by the mere fact that this is my
existence and you got to live with that
I live with it for a lot of years and so
I sat back and said okay all right I
know what this takes and when you sit
back as up as I was and I had a
laundry list a table like this of what I
have to do to become just a human being
that can make ends meat that can make a,
dollar a month just to get there was
like oh my god dude like
how I'm 16 17 I can't read I can't write
and I oh my God I'm so behind the power
curve and my brain is about being
depressed and my dad beat my mom's not
home and kids are calling me at
school and I'm like oh my God man what
the do I
do and it wasn't like someone came
around and said hey man you can do this
this is call me so people want know
where's this cold man come from I'm not
trying to be
cold it's the reality of my life it's
the reality of a lot of people's lives
and so yeah that had to happen for me to
be haunted to be haunted to pull out to
extract the godamn today that haunting
is something that's still there today
because no matter how much you improve
no matter how much you change who you
are it's not not
permanent you don't just wake up and say
oh my God man you're you're David
Goggins you break records you do this
you do that people want to know how are
you how are you able to just be so hard
because I never turned the thing
off because once it turns off I go right
back to the David goggin that is and
that's the guy that I'm constantly
fighting every day and it's a choice and
that choice makes you misunderstood it
makes you crazy that's why I hate
social media in
2013 people wanted me to write my book I
did it in 2018 took five years and the
reason why I didn't do it I set at a
table and Jennifer was there this before
I I I she started working for me I
started dating her whatever and all
these people were there and they're like
man you got to go on social media and I
was like you man like I'm not
that's it's it's poison it's poison
because I knew what I did to get where I
am and I'm going to have these people
these normal everyday people fat lazy in
exactly who I
was judging me because I know it because
I was once them all my hard work all my
dedication I'm have some normal dude get
his little brownie his little dingdong
ho ho twinky sit there with this coffee
picking me apart oh he must be unhappy
he's just know how hard it is to put
these shoes on every damn morning I
going have you pick me apart so yeah
there's there's a there's so much that
goes into this that I was like this
I never want anything to do with it so
anyway I'm not a
psychologist but knowing your story from
what you've written what you've said on
social media and elsewhere podcast and
here now especially right it's amazing
to me and frankly it pulls in my
heartstrings a little bit I realize
that's not what you're trying to do but
that in the course of your childhood and
in your young adulthood that no one ever
got between you and the world no I
forget where I heard it that like if a
kid has just one person that believes in
them right you know and I had my trials
and tribulations but I had great coaches
great mentors I attached to them I found
them if they didn't necessarily find me
right but I'm realizing that your
situation was no one's ever said hey I'm
gonna stand here next to you or get in
front of you right put a shield up and
so it's almost like you've got these
different ver it's all you but there's
versions of yourself that like you knew
social media like I don't know that I
have the wherewithal in 2013 14 15 16 17
right to get in front of myself while
doing all this CU I've already got so
much going on in here right is that
about right that is right but I had
developed a lot of anger and I still
have it it will never go away for the
normal human beings of this world
because when you put yourself in the
sewer like I was in and please if
someone saved me come out and announce
it to the world there's no one there's
no one so when you know that and then
I'm sitting at a table with all these
smart people are telling me what to do
and and guiding me through my life
now when I'm 40 years old you
know two I was I don't know 40 something
years old now I'm 49 and I'm looking at
them all and they're and they're now
trying to guide me on which right on
this
poison and so yeah what you say is right
but for me it was more of I know
now I don't need you to guide my future
I know what's good for me and what's bad
for me and for me it took every bit of
focus I could I know social media that's
why people love to go on there because
they want to show you the good side of
life I'm not teaching good side of life
so I had to figure out a way when I came
on in 2016 of teaching you what life
really is for the majority of us is hell
and so while people love to show you the
cars and the house and the vacations and
all that's good all that's Happy
I'm going to show you the side that I
know most you're going through and
people hide very well I don't want to
hide anymore I hit it for 24
years so that's why now when I told you
we can talk about whatever you want
because as human beans the one the first
thing we have to learn I also stutter
real bad growing up so if you hear me
stutter every now and then is because
that was part of my life also so it's
funny human beings want to show you the
best side and they want to hide the
worst side for me I'm going to teach you
how to be vulnerable cuz that's the only
way you fix yourself you don't fix
yourself by coming out here and me
selling you some books that's
why I don't have them I forgot them I'm
glad people got something from the
book I want you to learn that the only
way you
grow is how to look at yourself and say
okay like I did table longer than this
what the I have to do to get
somewhere there was nothing good on
there nothing yeah I love playing
basketball I left that out that's
something I love to do I don't care
about that that that didn't make the
list because the list that I had
to live by was it was the very list that
was going to get me at this table with
you to talk to you to the normal human
beings which I once was about how you
can get somewhere and how it looks looks
very
ugly there's no passion there's
no motivation there's no oh my
God man I this is no it's every
day of your life just
doing no passion no discipline no
motivation yeah all these words I hate
people I hate that so many people
use these words now because it's
watered it's someone sitting in the room
by themselves and they figure themselves
out and say God this is gonna
suck
where's passion when you're 300
pounds where's the motivation when you
can't read and write where is it so how
did this happen I just did I
just did I said maybe at the end of this
journey there'll be something there for
me if not I can
read if not I'm 185 pounds there
was not there there there's no magic
potion there's no oh let me wake up and
look at some no all those words are
overused they're it's all
just do you're living how do
you want to live how do you want to die
how do you want to be
remembered that's that's it that's it
period as many of you know I've been
taking ag1 daily since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast ag1 is a vitamin mineral
probiotic drink that's designed to meet
all of your foundational nutrition needs
of course I try to get enough servings
of vitamins and minerals through whole
food sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but often times I
simply can't get enough servings but
with ag1 I'm sure to get enough vitamins
and minerals and the probiotics that I
need and it also contains adaptogens to
help buffer stress simply put I always
feel better when I take ag1 I have more
focus and energy and I sleep better and
it also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you you'd
like to try ag1 go to drink a1.com
huberman to claim a special offer
they'll give you five free travel packs
plus a year supply of vitamin D3 K2
again that's drink a1.com
huberman the word haunted mhm is ringing
in my head
yep I think it's such a powerful word
yep because I was about to say seems
like a huge part of your process maybe
the entire process is it's all stick no
carrot you know you talk about the
carrot the positive thing and then
there's the stick the thing you're
trying to avoid yep I feel like it's the
way it's Landing for me mhm is it's all
stick and gas pedal that's it there's no
carrot you're not imagining oh when I'm
a paramedic when the book is published
and obviously you set those goals and
you make those targets y but it's all
stick all stick no carrot think about
that I'm waking up right now studying
like I have a test tomorrow I already
passed the
test think about that every day of my
life that's what I must do just to
retain what I
learned four hours plus a day I go
through and do that there's no stick or
there's only a stick there's never been
a carrot which is why when I speak to
people I have to figure out a way to
resonate with them because all I want to
say to them
is let me teach you the real life how it
really is the reason why you're a loser
and the reason why you're not
making it and the reason why you're
trying to go through all these I go to
all these conventions speak all
the time I look in the
audience and these people sign up sign
up sign up every year go to
Convention thinking they're going to
learn something different no
you're lazy you know exact exactly what
to do exactly what to do because even me
in my state of I can't read and write I
knew exactly what to
do it just sucks doing it it sucks to do
it it sucks to wake up every morning of
your life and say God man I'm I'm not
smart so guess what I gotta do I gotta I
gotta study the same that I got one
of the highest scores in the nation on
and do it again do it again do it again
it's not just there it's not just there
permanently for me so yeah it's all
stick it's all
stick the only care you have is
like
maybe maybe because whenever I take
these tests that are real hard in the
back of my brain it's like the good
chance you're not gonna make it Goggins
this ain't you
bro this ain't you you weren't born like
this this ain't you the real you bro
study all you want to but the second
that computer comes on with 150
questions this ain't you man and somehow
comes back I passed I passed again
passed again but that real me back here
every time is
saying that ain't you bro that ain't you
and I have to outwork that voice when
I'm taking that test and I get to a
question I don't know the answer
I'm like man and then say I told
you man that ain't you you 300 pounds
man you said at home you figure out how
to do your hair that's what you do how
to come to school with the reverse
baldness when you're
16 that's that that's that's you
so there is no get out of jail free
card this is why I say stay hard because
when you weren't given the gifts the
only thing you can do in life is is stay
hard and I know people cannot stand me
they can't stand this
talk this is all you can do there's no
magic pill or a magic potion all you can
do is outwork the man that God created
or woman in you and what that looks like
is unfun that's why I said do not do a
documentary on me because people will
not see the truth they will see what
they want to see is I don't want to live
like that good good and you will live
exactly the way you live now questioning
who you are wondering what is possible
wondering what you are capable of doing
that's how that looks or you can be me
which am I
happy I don't know never really thought
about it don't really care about it
because all I really cared about was I
looked in that mirror I saw a
piece of happiness wasn't on the
mirror at
16 around 300 lb it wasn't like oh my
I'm looking for happiness no I'm looking
look at myself for the mirr and said all
right you did it again
today you're a bad boy because that
sucks I have about a couple minutes of
that when I got the
carrot second lay down and go to bed the
carrot is gone because I'm waking up all
through the night to check the work I
did that
day I get this drug right did I get this
right did I get that right what did I do
oh my God I'm I'm already losing
it it's a
stick that stick is haunting you ha it's
following you around so no picture of
Jordan on the wall you're not listening
to YouTube inspiration video those would
be all your voice
anyway uh you're not U listening to your
top 10 favorite songs just to get
rolling and then lace the shoes hit the
books you're it's all in here all in
there I used to do that when I was fat
Rocky I me people know that that was my
thing uh round 14 was my thing and as I
got older and older and older that
started to go
away and I started to
create out all these people that I used
to watch Rocky was one Barnes Elias from
Platoon
um Jack from A Few Good Men you know
he's on the stand going crazy I saw a
lot of these characters that I looked at
and I was like man I ain't got none of
that but they were
characters after a
while I lived a life so
disciplined that everybody that I once
looked to these fake
characters I I I built that as a
man and when I was younger I had this
image in my mind of what does a man look
like to me and I got all these people
who are badasses
characters and in my mind I became that
and that's what kept me going a lot was
I had this pipe dream of becoming a
little bit of this and a little bit of
that because when you have no parents
raising you and you have no Role Models
growing up you it's not daydreaming you
start to create a reality
like maybe I can be
that and
after becoming this
guy that is the biggest thing I can ever
do in my life is I became that guy that
I once looked at all these guys now look
at myself like God who the can do
that I can but what it takes is a a
discipline that no one can ever
even they they just don't they don't
understand it they don't understand but
everybody has the ability to do it but
they just don't want to they want to
keep asking questions and keep going the
seminars and the greatness is right in
you and that's why once again I'll say
this a million times here I do not feel
sorry for you I will not sugarcoat what
I'm going to say to you because all of
you know what I'm saying is the
truth everybody knows the truth this is
what it looks like and you know it too
you know it too this is what if if you
ain't got nothing I hate to tell you
what it looks like it's ugly it's not a
documentary it's not a HBO special you
ain't going to watch hey man you guys
got this no it's like oh God this looks
like a train wreck like a nightmare this
looks like this guy got no that's what
it looks like hard work looks horrible
it's not motivating it's not motivating
at all ain't like Rocky round 14 he gets
knocked down and do that this to Apollo
Creed looks like a man being stuck in a
dungeon and there's no
way out but you have the
key but you refuse to use it and that's
nothing motiv about that so yes no doc
Me On David
Goggins the real life David Goggins is
the is the documentary it's all it's
already being
written you're it right yeah I'm going
to share a little Neuroscience tidbit
love it but I think it's one that you'll
appreciate um most people don't know
this but there's a brain structure
called the anterior mid singulate cortex
as we pointed out before that's a noun
it's a name it doesn't mean anything we
could call it the the cookie mon
right but what's interesting about this
brain area is there now a lot of data
mhm in humans got some mouse study
showing that when people do something
they don't want to do like add three
hours of exercise per day or per week or
when people who are trying to diet and
lose weight resist eating something
right when people do anything that they
and this is the important part that they
don't want to do right it's not about
adding more work it's about adding more
work that you don't want to do yes this
brain area gets bigger y now here's
what's especially interesting about this
brain area to me and by the way I'm only
learning this recently because it's new
data but there's a lot of it the
anterior mid singulate
cortex is smaller in obese people MH it
gets bigger when they diet M it's larger
in athletes M it's especially large or
grows larger in people that see them
elves as challenged and overcome some
challenge
right and in people that live a very
long time
mhm this
area keeps its size in many ways
scientists are starting to think of the
enter mid singulate cortex not just as
one of the seats of willpower right but
perhaps actually the seat of the will to
live see now we're talking and when I
learned about the anterior mid singulate
cortex I was like almost out of my seat
and I've been in the Neuroscience game
since I was 20 we the same age and I was
so pumped cuz I've heard of the amydala
fear prefrontal cortex it's planning and
action I could tell you every brain area
and every I teach neuro Anatomy to
medical students but when I started
seeing the data on the anter mid
singulate cortex I was like whoa this is
interesting yep and all the data point
to the fact that we can build this area
up yep but that as quickly as we build
it up if we don't continue to invest in
things that are hard for us that we
don't want to do that's the part that
feels so gogain esque to me that we
don't want to do like if you love the
ice bath yeah I love the ice bath you go
from 1 minute to 10 minutes guess what
your anterior mid singulate cortex did
not grow none but if you hate the cold
water if you're afraid of drowning and
you get into water and put your head
under
yep then you're anterior mid and survive
then the anterior mid singul cortex gets
bigger but if you don't do it the next
day or if you do it the next day and you
enjoy it cuz hey hey I did it yesterday
woohooo happy me Merry Christmas as you
say Merry Christmas guess what the an
mid singulate cortex shrinks again yep
to me this is one of the most important
discoveries that Neuroscience has ever
made M because it's that I don't want to
do something but do it anyway that's
right that grows this area and it's
almost like I have a friend he's been
sober 30 years from alcohol he always
says you know the amazing thing about
addiction is there's a cure the problem
is it only works one day at a time yep
and so you have to renew it every day
that's right so the anter mid singulate
cortex to me when I learned about it two
two things went off in my head whoa this
is super interesting and two I got to
tell David Goggins about this and I
waited until now to tell you because I
felt like I well for obvious reasons I
wanted to tell you and I wanted to tell
you here well I love that because that's
how I've lived my entire life I don't
know anything about that but people go
man you have such a strong
will it's something that you build like
I never forgot I was on a podcast one
time and this dude goes you were blessed
with a strong
mind
like the hell you talking about it's
blessed with a strong mind you that's
something that you have to
develop you developed that over years
decades of suffering
and going back into the suffer that's
why a lot of people who graduate Navy
SEAL training they want know like in my
I talk about very openly all the
time a lot of guys don't go don't want
to go back into that water they want to
go back into the hard stuff maybe not in
anything hard anything hard in life once
you get through it it's like you become
a
PW like how many PWS you know want to go
back to PW camp
none when something sucks so bad in life
this is on this that we're talking about
now very few people want to go back
they're happy they
graduated I realized I'm the same way I
don't want to go
back I have to go back I must go back
because that is exactly where all the
knowledge of my life exists was back
there and which you're exactly talking
about well I I didn't know anything
about this but how I grew a will was
constantly doing these things to now
it's just
life I wake up while it still sucks it's
just life you don't sit back and like oh
my God like I have days I don't want to
do but I know I'm GNA do
it I know from years of just doing it so
that that's that's beautiful and this is
why I came on here with you today and
I'm I'm glad you're talking about this
because human beings need to hear this
they need to stop hearing these
hacks on this and that there's no
hack bro there's no hack
yeah you may this and that and saunas
and all this that they yeah it's
great there is no life hack to
grow that thing how do you grow it do it
and do it and do it and do it that's the
hack the hack is going to suck
and that's what I realized that's what I
realized life that's why I wanted to
come on here today I didn't want to come
on here and talk about no
passion and purpose and how to get the
out of bed and how to hit a
alarm clock and all this catchphrase
because that wasn't how I
lived it wasn't how I lived I lived I
woke up like every human being does and
goes man I'm a piece of
today how the hell is this going to
work out for me and you fight that and
you fight that you don't override it
it's no override button it's the
conversation in your like in
your head so how do you do that we don't
have enough these conversations about
the real conversation that every human
being is having and they have no idea
how to get out of it but they
do it's that right there man you
got to build your will how do you build
your will exactly what you said man
exactly what you said well I feel like
kn the name of something anterior mid
singulate cortex doesn't fundamentally
change us but one thing I like about
biology is that willpower if somebody
feels they don't have it feels like this
thing that other people have but
everybody unless they're brain damaged
like a hole right through their head has
two anterior mid singulate cortex one on
each side of their brain everyone has
One MH they have two so I feel like it's
just a question of opening the portal
and the portal what I again I'm s to say
10 times and forgive me is I think
people go oh I do hard things I do sets
to failure and then I do four straps I
love training with weights I love doing
sets to failure I even like four straps
but guess what I like four straps so I
I'll tell you they don't build my
anterior mid singulate cortex right
because I like to do it that's right
anything you like to do is not going to
enhance this aspect of willpower and it
seems so obvious once you hear it you
kind of go oh yeah of course but I think
think you really close that Loop for
people when you share what you're
sharing today and what you've shared
elsewhere before as well when you're
trying to explain the friction is the
critical ingredient right and I think
people think oh if it's effort well then
I'm getting better that's part of it
necessary but not sufficient as we say
in science but the suck
part The Haunt being haunted the stick
MH they're really unpleasant terms very
these are probably the most unpleasant
terms we've ever used on this podcast
very those are the those are the levers
those are the gears and without those
this thing that you're talking about
David gogin as a verb right you know I
sometimes make the joke but it's not a
joke right goggin is a
name and it's a verb people go I'm gonna
goggin that right right but that's I
think again I'm not a psychologist but I
think that's what you're talking about
the stick the friction being haunted
it's the suck part that grows this
anterior mid singulate cortex so now you
know why there's so many people that
fail in this world to figure out their
purpose their purpose in life where do I
go because to grow
that M you may not look like me how my
daily life
looks it don't look
fun don't look fun
so it's a choice that people have to
make in life but what's so funny about
it is even the richest of Rich who have
everything they always ask me this
question I feel like I'm missing
something I don't feel like I'm missing
I don't have what you all have but
you'll never in my life hear me tell you
I'm missing something everybody is
they're missing this feeling
I found it long time ago I found it
right there in that willpower thing when
you're nothing nothing and change
yourself into something like
me you call it happiness peace whatever
the you want to call
it people are missing exactly what went
on with David gogins why don't you smile
I do I do but I figure something out
that's why I am never you'll never hear
me say I'm missing something I found it
years ago you find it in the
suck you find it in the suck and you
find it repeatedly in the suck to the
point where you know exactly who you are
most people are missing something
because they don't know who they
are they never examine themselves they
they've never done this experiment on
themselves the lab rat we're all labat
but you're also the
scientist you create your own self most
people are missing something because
they so much trapped in there I I want
to say potential I think that's word
used out too much too there's so much in
you that God or wherever the hell you
believe in or if you're atheist in you
that you have not un unlocked that you
walk around with this gorgeous wife or
or great husband all this money like God
I feel like I'm missing something yeah
because it's
about 75% of you is still in
there still chained up because you just
didn't want to find your willpower
didn't want to find your soul your will
your heart your determination your guts
your courage and what that looks like it
looks scary like your little scary lab I
went in scary to wake up every day and
say I'm stupid but I want to figure out
a way to be
smarter versus saying man I just can't
do that so you limit this box so your
box becomes so small of things you can
do my box wasn't even a box it was a
little like little pinhole and
then through examining myself getting
some willpower some courage it became
bigger than this table but that's what
we all do that's why I want to come here
today and talk to you about real
not no like hacks there's no
hacks bro it's you against you you
against you and if you miss
misunderstand that you have a real
problem real problem I can understand
you misunderstand me running down the
street shirt off this no yeah I can
I can get it I get it if you
misunderstand what I'm saying right now
today the problem is you and you don't
want to fix
it well the children of wealthy people
are a case study in how not having
enough friction can destroy a life true
statement I mean I could listen off
prominent names in the Press but those
are actually the least interesting
what's probably more interesting as an
example is all the ones we don't hear
about because we never hear about them
right they just dwindle and wither or I
think there's this big category of
people I'm realizing as we have this
conversation today that they're not
super successful they're
not struggling MH they're like
successful enough that they never have
to you can get to the point where you
don't have to
impose friction you even said it right
your bank account is in a place where
you don't really need to do all the
things you do probably not even a small
fraction of them do nothing right but
you realize the stick and being haunted
is the uh the fuel in the engine right
and you'd be a you'd be truly crazy to
give that up because you you've
internalized all that right but most
people they're they're good enough yep
for them yep and so they don't actually
want to be better badly enough in order
to start going wrung after Rong you well
think about when you build willpower and
think about how much I've
built now that you know about this this
I didn't know about this but think about
how much I've built everything I've ever
done in my life I didn't want to
do everything every day I'm a lazy piece
of
and I'm one of the hardest working
people that ever setep foot on this
planet Earth and I'm saying that very
proudly CU I know what I do it's not
cocky I'll tell you I'm stupid and I'll
also tell you the exact opposite of what
I've done it's the
truth it is the truth so imagine how
much I've developed in that time frame
but it's the scary
thing why most people don't want to do
that build that willpower is because
this
scary it unlocks a whole bunch of things
about who you are and who you're not and
a lot of people don't want to go down
that Journey
to discover who they are and who they're
not cuz it's it's not a pretty journey I
mean I've gone down it it's not like I
went down at once I go down it all the
time and when you unlock that and you
can't just turn it off like people say
hey how how come you haven't retired
yet I built all this
willpower do you think it's going to let
me
just retire because my my my knees hurt
is is telling me every morning I wake up
like man I don't my knees hurt mouth my
legs hurt my body hurts but you can
still run so why aren't you
running if you can still run there'll be
a time when you can't lace them up
anymore but you can still
run so I still run when the time comes I
can't run the body will say you just
can't run but if I can still do
something that willpower that I have
created it makes me do it every
day and that's what they don't
get what builds a human being is you
start with the small building blocks and
before you know it man you become
something that you it doesn't even make
sense to most people because it's just
who you are now that's why I can still
run at 50 with broke with at fornite
with broke down knees and broke down
body because my body knows you still can
therefore I do second you stop the
willpower is gone and that's beautiful
I'm so glad you brought that to me
because I always wonder
what's this separation thing
now at 24 years old I started building
something that I didn't even know was
going to be what it is now at 49 and
that's all it was was just
that this structure anterior mid
singulate cortex has inputs and outputs
from a bunch of places but you'll
probably not be surprised to learn that
it's strongly activated when we move our
body when we don't want to move our
body I feel like it it's like the David
go structure right it is and it also has
strong connections to the dopamine
reward pathway and everyone goes yay
dopamine everyone loves dopamine I'm
partially responsible for people knowing
a bit more about dopamine but dopamine's
badly understood everyone thinks
dopamine dopamine hits It's about reward
it's about motivation and drive and
there are pain inputs to the dopamine
centers of the brain no one talks about
that everyone's like oh you want the
chocolate you know chocolate sex cocaine
all yeah that's all true right release
dopamine pain releases dopamine the
anter mid singulate cortex can trigger
the release of dopamine in response to
this thing that we're calling
friction and that's a learned thing
that's something that no animal or human
being comes into the world learning we
all are averse to pain and like pleasure
like sugar fat don't like hot surfaces
right but this is a structure that
learns mhm it has neuroplasticity the
ability to change throughout the entire
lifespan and here's the part that I
think again is is just neuro nerd speak
for what you already know and have done
and exemplify is that it people will say
oh it has plasticity you can change it
guess what has PL plasticity in both
directions it can grow but just as
easily as it can grow it's like Silly
Putty it can shrink right so it requires
constant upkeep right and that answer
isn't one that people are going to like
nope they're like give me the energy
drink give me the supplement give me the
yes give me the sauna protocol that's
going to make my Anor mid singulate
cortex someone out there right now is
going wait if I took transcranial
magnetic stimulation and I stimulate
yeah you'd probably actually they've
done that they've stuck a little wire
during neurosurgery into this structure
this is actually discovered by a
colleague of mine Joe
parvey stimulate and the patients go I
feel like there's a storm coming and
they go oh is it scary and they go no I
want to go through it they come off the
stimulation and people are like this is
the seat of what we're talking about
right exactly and it learns so the fact
that you've kept this brain structure
I'm convinced if we image your brain it
be large and it would be larger in two
years a
year but this is the no days off
rationale because it can grow and it can
shrink I know what you're saying right
now I didn't know any of this and I
never and I always talk to people I I
wish I could just put this on paper and
you're saying it in a way that people
can understand I can never put in words
on what I
built and the power that is within all
of us but you put it so like in in a
scientific way most people like for me
he's just crazy that's why I don't like
talking about it man I know I'm not
crazy I know what I had to do to get
where I had to go
people look at as crazy because they're
people that just if you can't imagine
yourself doing something if you can't
imagine yourself doing something the
person that's doing it is
crazy because in your mind the logic
behind it it doesn't compute therefore
you have to give somebody a title and a
title for me is usually he's crazy he's
this he's that no
no for some reason me wanting to be
somebody so bad in my
life I created that and I've been trying
to figure out years of my life trying to
explain to people but even though you're
explaining it
now this is the easy part them
listening to this is the easy
part the part that why there'll
always be the ones of ones is because
putting that
practice putting that into actual work
no man no no that's where the demons
come in that's where you like I I don't
want to be better I don't want to be
better this what it takes to be better I
don't want to be better so everybody's
that's why there's a lot of average and
it makes me so mad every day I
walk this Earth and I see average all
over the place and they want to
ask me how did you do it I can't tell
you how cuz you're not going to
not going to do it you're not g to do it
you just you're going to continue being
out because every day you wake up like
he say it's not like get the
coffee make the make the
pancakes kiss the girl kiss the kids you
wake up right to work immediate your
mind is in action no one wants to do
that no one and I don't blame them but
don't be mad when you're laying there in
your bed and you're in the
hospital and you're 70 80 90
years old and you're
thinking man I feel like I didn't
do something because you did you
didn't do it you didn't do
you may lived a great life man but
you're always GNA feel empty inside I
don't feel empty so call me what you
want there's not one empty bone in my
body because I have figured out
that really the magic potion at least to
my life and it's very
rewarding I'd like to take a quick break
and thank our sponsor insid tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals now I've long
been a believer in getting regular blood
work done for the simple reason that
many of the factors that impact your
immediate and long-term Health can only
be analyzed from a quality blood test a
major problem with a lot of blood tests
out there however is that you get
information back about metabolic factors
lipids and hormones and so forth but you
don't know what to do with that
information
with insid tracker they make it very
easy because they have a personalized
platform that allows you to see the
levels of all those things metabolic
factors lipids hormones Etc but it gives
you specific directives that you can
follow that relate to nutrition
behavioral modifications supplements Etc
that can help you bring those numbers
into the ranges that are optimal for you
if you'd like to try insid tracker you
can go to insid tracker.com huberman to
get 20% off any of insid tracker's plans
again that's insid
tracker.com
uberman people like to talk about what
they used to be able to do I hear this a
lot you know you should have seen me in
high school I always laugh yep like yeah
okay got it um and it's not just guys
you should see me working out in high
school I was super fit um people will
look back to a time where they felt like
they were capable of something and now
they're not and you kind of want to just
grab them go wait that was you then it's
you now and but people tend to think
about how the
conditions that were around success must
have been part of it and you can
understand why it's like it's very
rational I was in that situation I was
successful I'm in this situation I'm not
that was the past this is the present
Ergo capable right you see how people
get into these loops and as you
mentioned you spent the first 20 years
of your life in extremely challenged
circumstances very and then you can see
how people get to a point where like
everything feels hard like when you're
300 lbs I have never been 300
lb but I can't imagine it feels good to
get up and move around he's defeating I
got a friend he's in excess of 300 lbs
we've been trying on him for years but
no no win and he's got crazy psoriasis
on the back of his calves and he he
actually smells bad sometimes because he
he um can't wash as well as he would
he's big big right and uh it pulls all
my sympathy right you know but life is
very hard for him and getting worse he's
young guy with a lot of medical issues
now for obvious reasons and so I think
people like that think well it's already
hard why would I make it
harder your message is a little
different and you have the life
experience it's a lot different you've
been there so for me saying oh yeah lose
weight you know I was a skinny guy who
got to be a less skinny guy so I don't
really have a foot to stand
on what do you say to those people who
are like listen I'm getting up in the
morning is hard trying to not dissolve
into a puddle of my own tears and my own
misery is
hard you know why people connect with my
book so well for some reason God put me
in almost every up situation on
the planet Earth so when I talk to
people it's not sugarcoated because I
I'm not saying it from I'm I 175 pounds
my whole
life I don't say much to those people
that's maybe you're a piece of
maybe you're you want to be nobody maybe
you're happy exactly where you are in
life because obviously you are maybe you
don't have the determination to be
somebody better than who you
are and if you want to live with that
I'll support you in that if you're good
with being who you are that every day
you wake up and every day you smell like
because you can't wash your body
well and your Skin's messed up because
your Health's so bad and you can't put
your clothes on right you need help with
that you help like when I was I need
help wiping my
ass that makes you feel
good nothing I can say to you if every
day you wake up with this see people are
haunted but they obviously like horror
films because they keep watching the
same movie I don't like horror
films a lot of people like horror films
so I don't say much to them I say
exactly what I said to you right there
because I always want you
I didn't like horror films so I changed
it some people are just they become like
you said it gets real small when you're
lazy and you're fat your
will their will is so small that they
don't have any and you can't give it to
them there has to be something this is
this is what I'm talking about now
because this isn't a hack this has to be
in you something in you has to wake up
and usually the only person that can
wake it up is
you sometimes you can read a David
gaggin book because I was all this
and then a lot more of
up but if you don't have a little flame
you know just that just barely you're
done I can't I can't light it for you
and that's the harsh reality of this
life that I want to get across so
bad you can watch me you can
watch you you can watch Rogan
and Cameron haes all these
you can go to Tony Robinson's
all this do all this
if you you could keep going back
and keep spending money and spending
money and spending money with no results
you're GNA wonder wow maybe let me go
try out David Goggins he ain't G to
help
you you have to explore examine the
insides of yourself and what do you
really want out of life your friend a
lot of people out here just don't
want it it so guess
what have fun with your life go from 3
to 350 to 400 to 450 to 500 because you
don't want
it and that's the harsh reality I can't
give you you can't give them
we give you ideas but in the day when I
was losing the
weight I had to miserably wake up every
morning in the cold because Indiana
November when it started I was
miserable this is your new
life take it or leave it there's no
happiness about it there's no peace
behind it it sucks it just sucks
and that's the one thing if I could
teach anybody anything it just
sucks and it's going to continue to suck
and then one day you get to a a special
part in your life that it might get a
little bit better but to lose the weight
you have to lose my
friend sorry it's gonna suck every
day because then when you're 300
pounds you're gonna go out to lose
weight you could probably get
injured so then you got to work on the
injury and then you get even more
depressed this is what I went through
and then you're hungry because now
you're depressed it's it's just a
vicious cycle and if you're not strong
mentally and you have no willpower
you're going to continue falling back in
this hole versus the man that sits back
and goes all right this is
why I cuss because this is what is in me
this this is what it took for me to be
me sorry it didn't take hey okay we're
gonna do this today no this
really sucks this is real dude this is
real and every day I'm I'm I'm I'm set
back I'm set back I'm set back I'm set
back so this what I would tell your boy
this what exactly what I tell him every
day you wake up you're going to probably
be set back for the first four weeks
before you lose to significant weight
because of the mind is going to be
with you the whole time there's
no
dopamine there's no dopamine in there at
300 pounds you got nothing your hormones
are
shot you have to Envision something that
is more powerful than
you something has to get you out of bed
and you have to create it it has to be
false because you're not it you're a fat
people piece of and that's the
reality of it so you have to
create a false reality to live in that
just to get to work on
yourself that's the
reality he'll he'll see this and he'll
appreciate that message we'll see what
he does so so far last 13 years it's
been no movement but I've had other
friends who uh who were drug and alcohol
addicts who quit after one conversation
never went back that's awesome that that
means they they want it yeah just one
one guy I won't out him but walked up to
me at a party in 2019 July Fourth party
and said uh I'm a pile and I go what and
he goes I'm a pile look at me I'm 60
pounds overweight I go do you drink he
goes every day I go how much he goes a
case he goes I smoke a lot of weed but
he's successful in other areas of his
life and so I said well here's what I
know quit alcohol and weed for you you
know I'm not telling people what to do
don't eat until 2 p.m. get on the
exercise bike and pedal in the morning
like someone's chasing you with a poison
dart till you want to puke and I was
kind of half joking right and then uh
two months later he was like I haven't
had a drink I lost 30 pounds he lost
that 60 PBS he never went back now he's
he's super fit it's amazing so some
people flip the switch he is very
self-critical by Nature that's what F
he's super self-critical yep that's what
flips the switch Yeah think about it man
we know what to do we don't need Angie
huberman to tell us what to do we know
what to do every one of us that's why he
flipped it so fast because he knew what
to do he didn't go by your exact
protocol he didn't go by the exact no he
knew exactly what to
do and you just saying some to him
it woke something up you knew what to do
and that's the thing that people need to
get that you know what to do why aren't
you doing it and I'm talking about
myself now you know those modes of just
kind of passive consumption they're so
easy to wash over us I used to have this
thing and I'm fighting this now because
I knew we were going to have this
conversation today where I like to start
things on the hour or the half hour
right worst practice in the
world for me because if I miss that half
hour I'm like ah it's 12:33 I'll start
at 12:45 right ah it's
12:45 I'll start at one I just lost time
right and then and so this is so stupid
right and the other day I was like man I
got to tell David about this because my
new thing is I start no matter what time
it is right if I wake up in the middle
of the night I got a friendy Paints in
the middle of the night I'm like you're
an insomniac he's like I don't know I
just do it then sometimes he goes back
to sleep sometimes he doesn't everyone's
got their thing but I thought about this
I'm like I'm no more am I going to say
I'm starting at 1 cuz I I know me if I
miss the 1:00 Ding and my Pen's not
hitting the paper not typeing in the on
the keyboard I'm not going to do it
right like that that's a self- admitted
weakness I love it man um I had that for
a lot of years um I know I'm going to do
it that's the haunting part is that it's
going to happen it has to happen and
that's a fact like
there's no get out of jail free car bro
none like that is a life that I don't
know I don't I don't have
that ability or I have the ability I
don't have the
um I'm not good enough smart enough I'm
not talented
enough to do
that some people are some people can
start at one some people don't have to
start at all if you lack Talent you
can't sit back and
say I start in half an
hour I can't do that I gotta start now
and after I get back from starting I
gotta start again and then when I get
done with that run or that study session
if it wasn't good enough I gotta go back
again because repetition is what is is
is what taught me everything so you can
honestly outwork anything but it's that
you obviously are a very talented man
well I I have worked hard at certain
things and built up some things that
I've been good at most of my life you're
amazing Gathering organizing and
disseminating information is something
I've been doing since I was a little kid
I used to give lectures at school on
Monday about stuff I learned over the
weekend see check that out but they they
took me to a psychiatrist we're the same
age back then if you got sent to a
psychiatrist me people thought you were
crazy one yeah exactly exactly so so I
remember feeling like a freak I also I
didn't have a stutter but I had a
grunting tip
it comes back when I'm tired and the
only thing that helped that was hitting
my head on something shaking my head
which is why skateboarding was good
because I'd slam and I'd feel like feel
good that's not healthy you know that's
not good or just work work is what gets
it out it's like an it's like a RPM or
high you know anyway that's me the but
yeah I think certain things over time I
feel like talenter gifts or whatever you
want to call them but there are many
things that are exceedingly difficult
for me and I and I have learned from
your example I know that you you are
very both humble and very clear that
like you don't have you say I don't
you're not going to get it by examining
you but I think the way you're sharing
today and the way you shared on other
podcasts before there are pieces that
really help people feel into the process
of what you're talking about today we're
elaborating on it I think a lot you know
this notion of being haunted and the
stick right I mean of course of course
now it makes so much sense why you don't
want to talk about sleep or rest or
recovery cuz that's not sure that's
important I've heard you say yes you
sleep yes you eat yes you hydrate yes
you you will stretch your soaz or what
but it's funny how that becomes the
viral message that's why I said
that today but that's not the unique
that's not the the unique message that
you carry like anyone can talk about
that so do I have that right that you're
acknowledging sleep is important
recovery is important but that's not
what you're about you have to forgo
something yes ice baths saunas sleep
nutrition all this so
important dude I don't have time for
some of it to get to extract where I had
to extract something had to give like
you talk about you when you were younger
you would you would give these speeches
and stuff the same age you were giving
speeches I was trying to figure out how
to say the without
stuttering and I realized I got older
that all these things are
important but for me to stop stuttering
I got build
confidence and speech therapy didn't
help that nothing helped that I have to
forgo a lot of to be as up
as I am to build confidence for me to
stand in the room of 10,000 of
one person and not and be like oh put my
head down let me look around let me let
me uh
read these paragraphs first and then
before I read the paragraphs because
they call me next let me just leave the
room kind with
stutter that's a miserable life and
that's one of many things I did besides
lying besides being insecure besides
being immature besides being fat besides
being one of the only black kids in my
school there's a lot of things I had to
overcome to gain
confidence and in doing so a lot of that
had to go a lot of it so I became the
guy became once again misunderstood you
only sleep four hours a day two hours a
day sometimes you don't sleep at all
like what's this and what's this and
what's this I know it's all
important I can't something's got to go
for me to get confidence because
confidence is the building block of
where I'm trying to go for me to gain
confidence in myself this up kid
has got to do a lot of up to
gain confidence and along the way the
stutter went away and I gained
confidence
and now my life is a little bit
more there there's no
balance there's no balance it's a little
bit more what it should be for a lot of
people but there'll never be balance
because confidence is something that you
constantly confidence and
belief You're Building every day and so
something's got to give and I'm want to
forgo a lot of things to have that
because I know that is that is if you
want to give somebody cryptonite
take that away from me so yeah I I
don't sleep sometimes and sometimes I
don't eat the right way and sometimes I
don't do this and do that and whatever
man but you put me in a room with 10,000
people any time of the day and I walk in
there think I'm the bad in
here because I know what it took to be
on this stage and a lot of people will
not do that so that's what it
takes there's a question I've been
wanting to ask you since we started and
I thought about coming in here and I've
been thinking about in the weeks ahead
of this and I'm going to just come clean
and say I don't exactly know how to ask
the question just ask it so it's about
relationships oh do it man
so I know in
myself that my discipline is much higher
when it's just me but that's because I
had certain things early on but then I
had I was a terrible student barely
finished high school but then when I got
serious I got serious but I did that by
staying away from
everybody and anyone's who who's ever
had a relationship of any kind but in
particular romantic relationships knows
that yes you can derive tremendous
support from those like you got this
baby you can go and you're like yeah I
got this she said I got this you know
feels great to finish something and
share with someone share a meal you know
get the hug but there's another side to
all of that right that I'd like to learn
more about from you which is there's a
warm body next to you in bed in the
morning you don't want to get up they
also have needs
you've got your mission that people
sometimes need things from us but also
oftentimes the people that love us most
that truly love us and that want to
support us don't understand this
thing and they're the first people to
tell us like
listen take a day off and then this
whole cycle at least in my head goes off
like you just want a vacation and then
it's almost like a paranoia I'm not
saying anything nice about myself right
now right good former girlfriends are
going to be like yeah like you know that
they remember they so and and so support
of people close to you is critical this
could be friends could be romantic
Partners whatever but they're also the
the knife Cuts both ways it can be the
thing that can really undermine this
thing that you're talking about because
the people that care about us also want
to see us comfortable right they want to
see us happy they want to see us
peaceful they want to see us in wake up
from a great night's sleep and they want
things too right so how do you untangle
that whole bit well it's funny man I'm
I'm unbalanced but I'm mostly unbalanced
towards the family side people don't get
about me I about being unbalanced I get
all my stuff in but what I do is I make
sure that my family has everything they
need everything they need those who want
to be part of my family some don't some
family members don't want to be part of
David ckins I get it I got it that's
life those who are part of my
family I give them everything they need
they can leave me the
alone I make sure you're happy as
cuz I got to go to work and I don't mean
smoke jumping I don't mean running I
mean all of it it takes every I can't
have you in my can't so I
know for me to have a family I gota make
sure that you realize I'm gonna give you
everything you need so when you start
bitching at me I'm G say look hang
on I dedicated my life to give you
everything you need I need this time
right here for me to be the best I can
be because this journey started without
anybody and I make sure everybody knows
that who comes in my life I've been left
think about it I was left alone at a
long at a young age to figure the
out I figured it out for myself and it
been very successful for myself no one's
going to come in here and with my
that's why I make sure I will take
care of whatever you need whatever you
need from me you got it
money house my love my support I'm going
give you everything you need that said I
do it the highest level possible I'm
saying it with Jennifer in the Next Room
so please come here and say something if
it's wrong Jennifer I don't give a
say what you got say so then when it's
time for me to go to work I expect you
to do the same for me because it takes
every bit of me to do what I have to do
so I make sure that I'm very unbalanced
for my family so I can be exactly that
unbalanced for myself and that's how I
do it I let people know right up front
I'm not what you
want in a man I guarantee that there's G
be a lot of late nights a lot of early
mornings a lot of times where I gota be
by myself thinking about the process
that is next in my
mind I can't have aggravation I can't
have this can't have that there's a lot
of things but I let them know up
front I'm very vocal about that
sometimes relationships work for me
sometimes they didn't but that's who I
am one thing I did wrong in my life was
I tried for so many years to please
people and I did it at the expense of
myself I was leaving a lot in the tank
and I and when you do that you stop
living but the person in your life is
happy as cuz you're giving them
everything they want they have their
their life is full but you feel empty
and that's not a relationship to me so
for me it's important that you know
exactly who I am because this is what
life made and I'm not trying to change
it because I just figured it out so I'm
not trying to compromise David gogin I
will
never ever compromise David Goggins that
doesn't mean I won't give you what you
need and what you want and what you
desire
but I don't need money I don't need Fame
I don't need so I give it all
way what I do need is to make sure that
that
willpower is worked on every day
and every night for the rest of my life
because that's the one thing that's
going keep me feeding you keeping you
where you need to be because once that
willpower is gone 300 pound David goggin
he may not be look like it but I will
walk around with it so that the things
that are important to you in life you
must do always or your nobody and that's
how handle
relationships Amen to that something I
could personally work on is that upfront
clear communication because I I it
resonates that feeling of like there's
something inside that's not getting
worked out that I was when I'm on my own
it's it's it's it's a lot easier but
then of course wanting relationships and
family I think that's a healthy part of
being human too and obviously you've
worked it out so I appreciate you
sharing that I don't think I've ever
heard you talk about scared man people
are scared of that conversation with
their wife husband girlfriend boyfriend
and but why are you scared of
it why are you scared to tell a
your wife your husband who
you
are who you are exactly who you are and
that was the problem I had that's a
problem that a lot of us have in life no
one knows who you really
are no one knew who I really was
I went to a school where there were a
lot of black kids a lot of black kids
didn't want to be in Special Ops I never
talked about special ops of black
kids why I was wondering what I'm not
going to fit
in that's not what they do a lot of
black kids don't do that kind of so
whatever I wanted to do no one really
knew the real me growing up because I
never want anybody to know the real me I
was always afraid of what you might say
or how you're going to feel or whatever
you got
feelings you have a life that you have
to live so it's important that whatever
is on your mind you let that person know
therefore you're giv them the option to
be with you or not this is who I am if
you don't like it that's good man I I
got it but this is David Goggins so
there that that honest conversation is
very important man so everybody knows
where they stand that person may not be
for you and that's all good this world
could use a lot more of the that upfront
completely honest conversation I feel
like so much of the world's problems are
because everyone's dancing around these
issues thanks a lot recently in the news
seen people losing their job because
they won't say something publicly you
can tell they kind of want to it's like
people just I think deep down really
crave the direct message like what are
you about what are you not about but I
think now everyone's afraid of getting
cancelled it's a big deal right you know
getting canceled that people think oh I
can't work if I am who I am or or um if
I'm not pretending to be somebody else
then you know silence is considered you
know agreement you know there's all
sorts of complicated stuff and I I do
feel for the generation coming up
because we didn't have social media
right and all of that that getting just
walled off from that there's a real
benefit from just not paying attention
people love to lie people love to lie
you know I thought I was the only person
gr like when I was growing up I thought
I was only person that lied because I
live in the bubble and people love to
lie about who they're not they love to
lie about who they're not dude and
that's for me the reason why I'm so
vulnerable and I'm so real and
honest find somebody come out tell me
I'm lying about my life and for
me to come where I came from and how the
resume I have now you know the
confidence you get how I don't care who
you gonna you gonna judge me you're
gonna judge me what have you done in
your life so me being so honest and so
upfront and so truthful that came with
me
finally figuring out who I was but also
conquering David Goggins the Demons of
David gogins therefore now you're just
an open book you look at somebody
looking right in the eye tell exactly
who the you are you walk away I'm
good bro I know exactly what this
journey took to get here and that gives
you a fire and a passion that people can
call you they can call you if
you're lesbian or gay or bisex call what
the you want if you put yourself in
the
fire and you come out of every
day like this press it off not scared to
go back in there again come on man your
truth is real you come out every day man
with a way of talking to people that
people don't have because there's no
truth behind them and the truth is a
starting line when you sitting in the
ugly mirror and say I'm this I'm this
I'm this I'm this you finally started
your life maybe 40 years old
maybe 40 years old five six kids wife
but second you look in that mirror and
you say I'm this I'm this I'm this I'm
this I'm this well basically I'm not
this I'm not this I'm not this I can't
do this I can't do this I'm all these
insecurities your life finally started
and once you start that life man the
truth comes out big time because you
don't care so that's the problem most
people just don't want to have that
conversation to the point where they can
go on stage with a million people and
say
I'm all of this and have a good day see
you it's it's empowering it's very
empowering I feel like the the way we're
educated in school but also outside of
school is we're trained as human beings
these young brains to try and figure out
how to get positive feedback from other
people yep it's like we're we're like
little dogs you got have a bulldog right
I had a bulldog saw the picture of your
Bulldog she's she's great they're
Charlie dog they're an amazing spe
they are I think of them uh economy of
effort y or amazing breed excuse me
they're an amazing breed economy of
effort they don't do anything unless
it's necessary it's kind of the exact
opposite of everything we're talking
it's kind of interesting that and
they're kind of heeding this now it is
true that they will they'll die to
protect you oh yeah and it's an instinct
I saw that with Costello I'm sure that I
saw with Charlie yeah it's it's an
instinct but if they're not in that
position if there's no need to exert
effort they're resting yeah so your
Bulldog's resting for you yes got it
exactly so you don't need to rest cuz
active recovery Charlie perfect that's
it perfect that's going to be your
answer from now on people go does he
sleep does he rest go no he somehow
worked it out so his Bulldog does it for
him
right but we're sort of indoctrinated
into this way of being from a time that
we're young where of course praise feels
good right someone tells you hey I like
that shirt or good job today or nicely
done or I for me CU I like grown up in a
big pack of friends growing up and I was
never the greatest athlete wasn't
terrible wasn't great Etc like a fist
bump or like a feeling crewed up and
you're just like yeah but you've talked
about this before in reference to the
SEAL Teams we both know a lot of people
in that community and the team's
component is a big part of it for a lot
of people and it's a wonderful thing
right but there's a danger to
that dopamine hit for lack of a better
way to put it from what we can only
derive when it's coming from outside
you're talking about being able to
either say good job but also like just
look to one's own personal history and
say I I've done hard things and I can do
it again and again because I do it again
and again and again you're talking about
parenting yourself yep inspiring
yourself yep scaring yourself all of
that from the inside so very different
than the way we're rais which is to
figure out how to get the biscuit it's
funny man people want to know how I'm
always
motivated it's the Unseen work which you
just say is a true statement those are
false dopamine hits that people are
giving you man there's no belief in that
these are teamw workk dope me like I'm
out running at 2 o'clock in the morning
one o'clock in the morning in the gym
long sessions by
myself you that's real how I'm able to
to just extract dopamine the good
dopamine whenever I want
man I've trained 99% of my life
alone no one packed me on the back I did
all of the work
alone and while I'm still hard on myself
I know what I did so whenever times get
bad for me people oh this who's going
carry the boats andot that's real I hate
that people know me for that guy cuz
that guy is not every day like
when they see me they want that energy
that's not me every day I can extract it
immediately when I need to because when
you train alone and I lived alone for so
many years in this misery and you're
able to get out it by
yourself I can take myself to such a
level of real real passion and purpose
and like the feeling I get is something
I can't even expl by I don't need anyone
that's why that's why people come to me
to motivate them no one can motivate me
I have a resume full of
motivation that whenever I'm down like
oh hang on oh you know you
know the truth you know the truth you
know the darkness of the
Dungeons and the demons that fly
you know and then from there it's like
okay you were there you know this there
was no one there to pick up the ruck
sack to pick up the boat to pick up the
log to go in that it was you it was you
there was no pat on the back at
300 at at 275 at 250 at 220 no that was
you so those things that come out of me
that extract from me in the darkness
people are looking for that P on the
back where is it oh I don't need it
because what I've done is in the
unseen work I've built
Frankenstein so whenever gets nasty
David Goggins goes
you had nobody anyway so
see I'm talking myself right now that's
me that fires me the up that
makes me nuts you had
nobody anyway look around
you there was no team it was you
there was no weight loss program or Mom
and Dad waking you up saying you can do
it you can be better trying to build
belief you built belief when you had
nothing Rock Bottom you did that so as
times get hard for
me the truth comes out and my truth is
powerful as it's real it's tangible
I feel it it comes out of my brain as I
speak about it I'm Rel living every
single dark moment of my life to be
here so that is what people don't get
that is what motivates David Goggins is
the Unseen work but every everybody
needs that P on the back they need that
training partner they they need that
accountability coach I don't need that
and neither do they but it's what
we've trained ourselves to believe that
we need it's almost like there's this
pill on the Shelf I'm speaking in
analogy right and we take it and we get
jazzed up we're like yeah but there's
this other medicine cabinet behind there
and it's in US you're saying the the
real medicine cabinet is inside oh yes
when you can continue to
overcome and I had so many obstacles to
overcome so it's actually a benefit to
me but the benefit is not like a benefit
like that you have to have the courage
and the patience to overcome and
overcome before you know it man you have
a whole medicine cabinet but there's no
medicine in the there's no
pre-workout I don't take none of that
all I got to do is flip my
brain put my finger in there and say
okay that's that's a good one it's all I
got to do man I got the roll ofex of
just like go yourself Goggins and
oh but you won let's do that one today
there's nothing I need and this is the
thing that people don't get about David
gokin I can't teach it in a one minute
video we all have this
ability to have our own medicine cabinet
but unless you go in there and put the
medicine in there
it's always going to be empty
man you're always going to need the
Pre-Workout you always GNA need to I
don't drink coffee I don't do c I don't
do none of that I don't need I I can run
for 70 hours and I had before no
caffeine I got all this wonderful
that I overcame On My Own by myself in
the darkness that man when it's cold I'm
hot when it's hot like I I I can feed
myself all all the time and that's why
when people say man why aren't you
missing
anything I can't explain it to you man
can't explain it to you you you you'll
never understand that's why I don't do
all these podcasts dude I got I love you
man that's why you my first book you did
a blur for me that's why I'm here I love
what you're doing for people man but I
can't explain this I can't I can't
explain this because people don't want
to do this they don't want to do this
man but
it's I don't know man I get I get jazzed
up even talking about it man because so
many people think my life is just so oh
God his life is horrible like don't
don't follow him he's crazy
really but there a good number of people
I would say and that's that actually do
I think it I what I'm hearing today and
it's really sinking in is that a great
many people either partially or
completely misunderstand you yes I'll
put myself in the partially category big
because I thought it was is about just
like forward Center of mass carrot
carrot carrot carrot but it's the stick
it's a sck and it's being haunted and
you know I do have examples from my own
life which is not what today is about
about being really afraid and then
turning things around right my biggest
fear is getting comfortable right I do
not have as much of a stick oriented
approach but today's conversation's
changing the way I think I'm not going
to step away from this and think okay
25 neural circuits that can explain 10
other the things that David's talking
about and what I'm thinking about is the
fact that everybody has a brain they
have a
mind forget the brain the brain is just
the physical structure but what that
manifests what that creates is the
mind and everybody has that so I do
believe that everyone has the capacity
to do what you're talking about at some
level I also will be the first to
confess that I think you're are highly
unusual let's just say maybe even n of
one as we say in science sample size of
one right somebody who's created this
process for themselves and keeps them in
this themselves in this forward centered
Mass with the stick battering the back
of their head all the time right highly
unusual but this internal medicine
cabinet that you're talking about
building up true confidence not needing
anything from the outside I think I like
to think MH
that people want that they want to be
known they're
afraid but that they want to be known
for who they really are and that you're
describing the path to do this right and
I will say I'm immensely grateful that
you're talking to us this way today
about things that you've talked about
before but we're hidden it a little
differently I like to think very
different
because what you're talking about is a
process it's verbs it's all verbs all
action and it's not about
success it's more actually about keeping
that friction dialed to 10 right and
that I no energy drink no supplement
people often misunderstand me they think
you know like I'm big on people getting
sunlight in the morning so they set
their circadian rhythm and get better
sleep so they can Etc but then people
always think they go straight to the
supplements yeah what should I take you
know and then of course people think I'm
all about supplements and supplements
are one piece for me but it's like tiny
fraction compared to the the doing the
dos and don'ts that's why they want to
talk about that today that's why I'm
glad we're talking about this this is it
this is it like the brain is the most
powerful weapon in the
world and it's it's crazy how a kid that
wasn't real smart I was forced to go
only
internal external had to go away the
external world had to go away and living
so deep inside myself it was me in this
brain and figuring out how this thing
works and it's so many people are doing
exactly that the supplements the this to
that and I agree it helps but once you
figure out your your
brain you become
Unstoppable to almost anything yeah you
can't beat Death you can't whatever
whatever your brain is amazing once you
feed it the right
conversation the right mental nutrients
the right mental complements the right
the right internal dialogue at the right
time with the right hit with the right
proof of what you've done in the past
and you send that right to the right
circuit dude you're a beast a
beast but once
again you just can't read about it you
can't sit back and be a theorist you
have to be a
practitioner and in that practice is
where that becomes proof positive what
I'm saying is like God like David Goin
he's blowing my mind what is this he's
not crazy and so many
people a lot of
people have listened to me the right way
and they come back and they're
like I'm totally on board I it happened
it happened I'm
like it'll keep going man if you keep
doing doing it but that is it man
there's no
sun there's no glory there's no carrot
Victory but there is all of it in one I
can't explain it real well to people man
but what you get the other end is
something that you're not you're always
found you're never lost anymore doesn't
mean the Journey's easy doesn't get any
easier but you're always
found I love that I just want to hover
on that for a sec the same same way we
hovered on haunted and the
stick I think people feel lost I've
certainly felt lost at times in my life
um many times and yeah there's that
thing I don't think there's a
neuroscience or a psychology term for it
someone will say put it in the comments
and say oh yeah that's what so and so
said but like you said we're not trying
to be theoretical here we're trying to
be practical the business of finding
yourself and knowing
like but it's sort of like I'm safe
because I'm in danger and I've been in
danger before and I got myself out it Al
always seems to come back to verbs again
I don't have a language for this you
know for once I'm lost for words there's
like it's it's about a a process the
algorithm and you're and the reason here
I'm just kind of try to make sure I'm
understanding things correctly one of
the reasons why it must be uncomfortable
for you to be who you are publicly is
because people want to focus on the
running or the swearing and by the way
the swearing is is welcome I'll tell you
I came up up through
Laboratories where all three people I
worked
for swore a lot but there was one rule I
couldn't swear at people so my graduate
adviser brilliant woman unfortunately
she died early they all died
early I'm the common denominator I had
that internalized for a long time anyway
she said but if you swear at people
you're out right but you can swear as
much as you want so that's that's the
rule I have it's like you can swear as
much as you want just don't swear at
people if you swear at people better be
ready to fight right definitely not
going to fight you so you can swear me
get away with it but the fact of the
matter is that it must be frustrating M
that people because I know people go oh
it's it's all about supplements and Ice
baths listen I like supplements I love
supplements and Ice baths but that's not
the full picture they just a
gravitational pull it's the swearing
it's the running it's his feet that are
all messed up it's the fact that he got
a Triton yeah this seal guy yeah talk
about that too right you know and
there's a gravitational pull for people
people and they're missing like the
that's like the tip of the iceberg is
what I'm realizing I'm realizing that
today thanks to the way you're phrasing
things cuz the bigger vessel is all in
here and and as you said how do you put
that in a book it it's impossible
because it's highly individual you do it
your way yes and you're saying everyone
needs to go figure out how to do it
their way for them yes and the thing
about being misunderstood is very
frustrating more than I can even imagine
I I can't even express how frustrating
it is
when the cussing and everything comes
from a place of of of real I can't
explain what I do without it the passion
comes out of me it's almost like
speaking in tongues because when you put
that much work and people go oh yeah
there's been this basketball player this
football player
this
dude no no
everything everything is work everything
and people don't don't believe it so
when I
speak the and the and the
and and and the and that is
what it took for me what it takes for me
the anger the passion
the the the the jawdropping just it
takes that because I'm not that
this is how I look at it
man what built this guy let's imagine
being in the coldest water you can
possibly take I always go back to hell
week with this I hated the water hated
it you're sitting there locked arms and
you're in the water all the time and
they're bringing you in and out of the
water in and out of the
water when you have this dialogue in
your head and these people are judging
me off of a freaking one minute
video and you're constantly your whole
life when you figured it out 24 I gotta
I I just gotta this got and this
is just going to suck every day is gonna
suck and live like that to be better and
I put this right I'm in the water the
water's going over my head the Pacific
Ocean you know it's
freezing February cold as been
through three hell
weeks for you to constantly win win win
when this voice over here the real you
is saying get the out of here go
you're nobody you've always been nobody
and it's
true people don't hear that that's a
true voice that's a real reality of
David
Goggins at 24 years old it's not a false
reality and then you had to create
another voice over
here that is saying you're better than
that other voice and you're in the
freezing cold water that both voices
don't want to be
in but you
win and goes from the water to the
studying to the running to the losing
weight to how you eat to how you
function as a man every day of your life
you're winning these
battles and then I have normal
people who only have one
voice never created the second voice the
winning voice is a second voice they
have one
voice and that's just I'm a piece of
that's all they hear and then they
judge people like me who are out here
trying to be
better it's something that I can never
really it's a frustrating thing for
me because I know I know the majority of
people I know what goes on brain because
I studied the mind more than almost more
more than you cuz I wasn't I'm a
practitioner so for you to be a piece of
and come out of that you don't just
come out of it you spend
decades studying your mind and the human
mind on how it functions in good
environments bad environments stressful
environments patient environment you
studied all because you had to put all
this together to create the mind to
become successful so I had to what God
blessed me with this brain I had a
create a mind and so in doing so I
figured out every piece of human
being in the world because that's what I
was going off of for
myself so I know why you go on Instagram
I know why you because you just have the
time you have the time because you don't
want to put that time into bettering
oneself so I know why I misunderstood
I'm misunderstood by people who have
plenty of time on their hands to
misunderstand me because they are
exactly where I once was where is a
lowlife lazy piece of and it's the
harsh reality of people who troll you
who go after you they have nothing
better to do with their lives it's not
some after school special it's the truth
by once was that way I know where it all
comes from that's why it's frustrating
me now cuz I'm not so frustrated at the
fact that I'm being trolled I'm
frustrated about the fact that you don't
have the
courage the courage to try to be
somebody better than which you're not
and that's the frustrating
part it's interesting because earlier we
were talking about relationships and you
said in a very candid way and I really
appreciate you sharing that that you
make sure that the people close to you
your family has everything they need
right and that they also understand that
you're going to take what you need to
continue to build you right period
period in some
ways it seems you've also included the
general public in that family you're
saying
listen I'm going to give you what you
need I'm gonna give you as much of
myself as I can except I'm going to stop
right at the line that's right that if I
were to cross it is going to prevent me
from continuing to build myself and by
the way this relationship only exists
because I don't cross that line that's
right and I think as much as there are
detractors out there or people that try
right I mean it's pretty whatever
they're doing is pretty feeble in my
mind I mean it's like cap gun fire you
know if if that very Fe you
know so many of us men and women old and
young hear something and feel something
in your
message like yeah like it seems kind of
crazy gosh like doesn't he ever just
relax you know what about his sleep you
know look at his feet he's going to he's
going to injure himself I've heard
listen I'll be very direct I got friends
who were in the teams who just go yeah
what's he going to do when he can't run
and I know the answer is keep running
that's right right but it's more
comfortable for people MH even high
Achievers especially High Achievers to
believe that if you took one thing away
that it would all go away it's
absolutely clear that's not the case
with you I'm 100% convinced I just know
that because what we're talking about is
this do many times I haven't been able
to run two heart surgeries multiple knee
surgeries and after every KN service
they say you're not going to run again
and I'm fine with
that there's no running up here bro none
this was what it was all about that's
what they lost if you can't run give a
it was never about running why do
you think I run it's the worst thing I I
hate doing it more than
anything hence the willpower right your
anti mid singulate cortex would start to
regress if you loved running think about
it every day I wake up I don't just run
a mile two miles it's the one thing I
hate the most to do and I do it like I
love it 250 60 7300 mile runs at one
time no sleep in every step when I get
to think about this I get to the
startline cussing at Jennifer why the
am I here I hate this
after 70 some hours of running every
question I ever had is
answered every question I had is
answered I cap
success I don't people go what do you
mean you cap
success for me to be who I
am so when I go smoke
jump I'm smoke jump three to four months
out of the Year sometimes five can you
just for those that aren't uh educated
about uh just like give us a brief
description of what smoke jumping
entails so basically you you jump into
fires not into them but you jump by
fires that people can't get to so out of
planes and helicopters right out of PL
parachute it's all parachuting so you
parachute out of airplanes and then you
fight the fire you and sometimes four
other guys or maybe eight other guys
guys and gals and you're putting this
fire
out so I lose millions of dollars every
summer to do
this it blows people's minds why the
hell are you doing this and you're
breathing s being s knees are jacked up
H hitting the ground hurting whatever
talking to normal people They never get
it so I don't even explain it to
him but this is why this why I call Cap
success I'm talking financial success
for me to continue having that
willpower the
second I just become a speaking monkey
and travel around and speaking gigs 12
months out of the year put camps on do
this put on lectures get supplement
lines and do this and write more books
and I've
ruined the exact thing I worked on my
entire
life and while I didn't know it until
today but something always told
me this is a very very very perishable
skill this this willpower that you have
cuz I do have a willpower that I have
never seen in anybody in my life it is a
haunting force that just keeps me going
and I know that that is my strength if
you have that
so that's worth every dime I've ever
made in my life is the fact that I can
look a man in the eye finally and have a
real conversation without going like
this because I'm lying or I'm a pie of
or I know you know how a person in
so many people do this they're
talking to you
on who they want to be they're lying to
you and they walk away I've done that so
many times you walk away like God man
why can I just tell him the truth why
the hell can I just tell him the
truth you know how good it feels for me
now to look at you in your eye and every
man a man I see because women won't get
this women will not get this manto man
that man you look in another man in
the eye and you know that everything
you're f saying is real and it comes
from a real working Place something that
you earned it's the best feel in the
world you can say that actually happened
like I know with certainty what I'm
saying actually happened actually
happened who I am and who I say I am I
am no more lies no more skirting the
truth no more and that is worth
every dime I've ever made in my life and
I is I swear to God on that every dime
I've ever made in my life building who I
built so I cap success because I know
that if I ever go 12 months out of the
year and don't put several every day I'm
going at it but several months out of
the year I go right back to Ground
Zero which means I'm just David
goggin no Goggins no carry boats
logs it's just pick up that
pilas and
dig hey get that pump walk down
a mile put in the water
mosquitoes beating you're just David
goggin you're nobody because that's
where my growth is that's where my
willpower comes from and that's where it
stays that's why I talk to you now and
then can talk like this dude people
don't talk this kind of passion because
it ain't there it ain't there they're
they're regurgitating some from 30
years ago I'm reging taking
from an hour ago hour ago
come on man it's
just be real and I can't be on these
podcasts I can't talk to anybody without
being real I'll go away I'll just go
away because I I can't give you what I
want to give
you you said perishable skill I think
that's another word set of words I want
to highlight because skill implies
behavior and when we were just talking a
second ago about the Deep true bedrocks
sense of confidence that comes from
looking someone in the eye and telling
somebody something that you absolutely
know it's true because it happened
you're talking about actions not talking
about perceptions you're not talking
about what you believe happened you know
it happened and there's something really
concrete about actions I mean that's
what's so interesting is we're talking
about the mind but actions are the
manifestation of the mind and I and the
stuff that just stays in
here people die with that it doesn't go
anywhere I I long ago somebody said you
know I forget what the context was it
was a neuroscientist he said you know
most emotions like they're just emotions
they're just in there like you don't
have to do anything with them and I
think certain emotions you want to do
something with right but I think people
forget this they feel miserable like
they're going to dissolve into puddle of
their own tears no one ever died from an
emotion right but they feel like that
they overwhelm us as if it's a tital
wave it's going to pull us under and
drown us it's so interesting to me
because I think what people listen PE
you have a gravitational pole people can
feel the energy I think yes you're
either completely badly or partially
understood there's only one guy on the
planet that truly understands you I
think there's one woman Jennifer who
probably understands you as much as
anyone's going to and then the rest of
us are kind of grasping trying to figure
it out right but you're saying go inward
MH so first go Inward and then it's
actions Inward and actions now the
inward piece is something I'd like to
just spend a little bit of time on
because there couple characters from
history people that were in
concentration camps Nelson Mandela I
mean I'm not sure he had Instagram in
there I'm pretty sure he didn't right
and I don't think there was anyone
coaching him on like hey you're going to
get out someday and actually you're
going to lead an entire country I'm
pretty sure that's not how it worked he
had to find it here he had to find it
between his ears right and there are
other examples but that's an important
one so the process of going inward does
it for you and here I will ask for
suggestions because I think people want
there are those of us who want to build
this skill
right wall yourself off phone off yep
for big portions of the day
perhaps texting off the requests the
this the
that anyone that knows you knows that I
we've communicated a few texts but most
of it comes through a filter she's great
she knows you you know and she knows
knows how to protect your time and that
hurts people's feelings people get mad
about that hey God bless God bless you
Jennifer you
know cutting oneself off when you're in
there you say it's just
you and the voices that come up are not
pleasant and then at some point it
converts to
action okay how much what is the process
picking the action that's the piece that
I feel like we there's like a a bridge
to build here if you can if you would so
the action be like like like what's next
yeah so like when you go go to sleep at
night when that
happens you know what you're going to do
the next day it's pre-planned yes okay
yes it's it's always the same thing
you're not building it on the Fly no
nothing's on the Fly nothing so how it
works internally for me is I'm I put it
exactly how it is I'm an
artist and every day I'm put I'm I'm
painting mon
Lisa every day and but it's a different
one it's not the same painting so every
day I wake up even though I do the same
thing it takes a different way to get
there so every day in my mind I'm going
through my mind I'm just
like and a good painter will not just
paint he needs to create and you can't
create with phones and everything going
around you so you got to block yourself
off you only do two podcast in a year
you block yourself off and you're and
you're painting this thing inside and
you're going through all these different
colors of paint and everything else and
you can only figure out the right
painting if you spend the correct amount
of time in your brain so every single
day I'm literally going with my mind and
I'm painting I'm creating this this
masterpiece and the Masterpiece is
always myself and but to do that you
cannot have any distraction actions
because if you're talking to an artist
and he's trying to think about the next
painting he he can't it's impossible to
listen to you and listen to what your
mind and body are telling you we must do
people don't do enough of they don't do
any of it you're they don't have passion
they they lack passion Drive
determination because you haven't spent
time with yourself your mind will tell
you what is
next but you haven't spent the time to
go all right let me just figure this
out you're looking for let me Google
this and let me Google that and let me
you're not going to find it there
because there's billions of people in
this
world and they're all supposed to be
individuals but we have a pack
mentality that's why you're so
lost why am I so
unique I'm being exactly what the I
was supposed to be I a follow and
when I did follow I was like
everybody
else the second I said okay man hang on
dude you don't like this you don't like
this you don't like this who are you
David goggin who are you supposed to
be miraculously all these things
just I I couldn't even the the list of
I had to do just Wham it's like
okay wow once you sit down with
yourself and say okay I don't want to be
like Michael Jordan or Jim Brown both
were on my birthday so I looked at their
birthday like oh my maybe be one I
can't I'm gonna be David
gogins and that looks like this it just
came everything flooded so every single
day of my
life there's a different thing that
comes up that have to do but no one
knows what to do because everybody else
is following steps
like the Republican and Democratic
parties I'm not political neither am I
at all for this reason Republicans are
going to vote
Republican Democrats are going to vote
Democrat you're not even a human
being bro no way all you agree
with all the same
and I know I don't so once you
figure out yourself and who you are all
the answers come so every night
a different painting is being painted
and it's a beautiful painting for myself
I'm like okay that's that's it it may
look the same to most
but the end result is very
different that's why my La I if
you look at what I've done in 49 years
it's more than most people ever do in
their life because they were a race car
driver that's what they did they drove a
car it's
great I was all kind of because
that's exactly what the painting was
saying to do what the mind was saying to
do one saying this driver a cars to them
that race car driver know what the
to do he he be tires from being a race
car driver and they're lost people how
how are you still I don't get it dude
you're never going to fill your list but
you never found your list because it
never was presented in front of you
because your head was cluttered with
because you never just stopped for
lots of minutes
lots of years and just said all right
it's me and you let it go and it just
bam it's right there it's right there
I'm not a psychologist as I mentioned
before but I'm going to venture a
hypothesis
here I
think that you've mastered the process
of internal dialogue but when I say
dialogue I think most people think oh
the the inner voice the the the chatter
but that's just one half of a dialogue a
dialogue is a two-way
street so I completely agree because I
know from experience that when we go
inward often times we hear things if
we're really honest with ourselves it's
like I I don't want to think about that
or that no and then we start looking
outward or we start trying to shift our
attention and
distract and there are a million reasons
that are handed to us excuses and
seemingly good justifications to be able
to do
that but dialogue is a two-way street
and it hit me while you were just saying
what you were saying I was paying very
close attention and I realize David
goggin is talking about the voice that
comes up including the terrible stuff
that no one wants to hear about
themselves from themselves but then he's
also got the dialogue down where he
knows the counter voice that's right he
goes yeah you're right and so I'm going
to do this or
maybe no remember this you're in a
dialogue a two-way dialogue in there not
a one-way chatter dialogue there are
books written by famous psychologist
about chatter trying to shift your
internal narrative you're like bring the
internal the internal narrative that's
what going inward is about but it's not
one voice again there's a hypothesis I'm
not claiming to be all knowing Lord
knows I'm not all knowing okay but
you've mastered the dialogue and if
there three
voices strong medium and weak in there
you're you're like let's all come to the
table so you've got a a a symphony of
voices in there that are all you that
you know to be you right and you know
how to have those convers you're not
afraid to be in those conversations and
then you know which what the outcome of
that committee decision is and you put
it into real world action and the world
only sees the action that's it and only
you can know your do internal dialogue
and only I can know my internal dialogue
and the only way to quote unquote know
it is to spend a hell of a lot of time
there that's right okay a lifetime got
it a lifetime like think about it for me
to be sitting here in front of you
you're not going to call 300 PB eolab
guy to come sit here you might I don't
know maybe probably not probably not
think about
this what we teach people is kind
kindness to
yourself do you think if I taught myself
kindness and I agree with it guys so
many people so many people take me out
of context it's
ridiculous take it however you want
to take it when I was 300
pounds where you think that conversation
would have got me if I spoke kindness to
myself I tell you where it gets me right
back to 7-Eleven another box of mini
chocolate donuts and a chocolate
milkshake that's the one
voice that's the one voice that most of
us have that you're talking about if you
don't have a conversation in there the
other voice that you create that says
okay how does this look looks very
ugly that kind conversation for me went
away a long time ago which is why the
dialogue is now which you see a lot of
action because most people have inaction
because there's one person talking and
that one person's always leaning you
down the same path the path that makes
you feel
very comfortable and happy with
yourself the second you create the other
voice there's
conflict there's battles there's
Wars there's defeat one thing I learned
I taught myself this and people go I
don't understand what you're saying I'm
G try to break it down real
quick I didn't teach myself Victory
first I taught myself
failure I taught myself how to
fail
and people go that's so depressing is it
when you're 300 pounds and you can't
read and write and you're up how
many times you're gonna fail on
that process so if you don't know how to
fail there is no
Victory I never talked about winning
because I knew the path to winning was
to be years of failing first so I taught
myself how to fail
properly no one teaches you how to
fail
but if you're going out for
insurmountable odds that make
absolutely no sense a black kid
that can't swim 300 pound will be a Navy
SEAL
okay you better teach yourself how to
fail first because if you sit in failure
for too long you will never come out of
it so the first part of My
Success was learning how to fail
properly
and then
eventually I started getting a few
victories but that's what people don't
get when you have buried yourself in
such a deep hole you better
first talk about the failures you're
going to have first and that's when that
other voice comes up it tells you we got
to do something but it also tells you
boy I'm not gonna lie to you goggin
you're in for a climb bro you're
going to get your ass handed to you made
fun of the outside noise the inside
noise both voices are going to be
telling you to go yourself
you are in for hell
bro I am so brother Le to fail so this
is what you mean when you say that
whatever anyone says it's insignificant
insignificant as right it's the cap
gun fire because it's just like it
because the voice in your own head is is
far worse and I should say sorry one of
the voices in your head yes yeah I'm
being very like detailed almost surgical
about about that because I think this
thing about inner dialogue we think is
one voice yes but you're making it clear
it's many voices it is and the thing
about it
is you you you have to be really and
sometimes all the voices are telling you
the wrong man but through Years
Years not a podcast or listening to a
book or reading a book years of
sacrifice of suffering of diligent
pinpoint work on what you want
to do for yourself not like oh let me
just do a bunch of let me I want to
be in every task possible no pinpoint
what I want to do with my life what
happens is you have all these voices
that are telling you you're up
and this is could to be hard but for
some reason you put so much practice
into
you that you can ignore every one of
them that are telling you you're not
going to make
it and still be able to make
it because you have put the practice in
that you know this is the process it's
such a daunting task that all the voices
are saying no but you still have the
conviction that I know I can do this and
that's what it took for me to get
here 20 30 years ago I had this 35 or
whatever it was 30 to 25 years ago pipe
dream and ever since then every voice
was like you're a
nut but when you put that practice in
every day you lay them up and I don't
mean run it's just a metaphor for life
when you lace them up
every day pretty soon you win pretty
soon you'll win if you had the
courage in the heart and the dedication
and the mindset about everybody can go
themselves I know what I know I've
listen to myself enough to
know I know what I know none of you can
hear what I'm
hearing and that's where people don't do
enough of they don't listen to their
Journey they listen to everybody else's
before you know it I'm crazy but if
I'm so crazy why am I so
successful how that
happen I'm
so misguided and Mis and up and
don't listen to
him
why am I the only one to do a whole
bunch of why am I a
Trailblazer why how is that possible how
can you be up and also self-made
the same no no
obviously you're not looking at the
truth in front of you the truth in front
of you is it sucks it's
painful it's
mind-numbing and that is the truth and
that's why a lot of people don't like
listen listening to me cuz this is what
it takes creating another voice and
sometimes going at it alone all the time
going at it alone because no one's GNA
believe in you and that's
that what I'm about to say is not
conjecture and I can say that with
confidence because I did a four episode
guest series with a brilliant
psychiatrist a guy named Paul KY from
Trenton he's a Stanford Harvard trained
guy he's also got a lot of Street and
him he's had his own hardship real
hardship he brilliant and he said
something that I'll never forget which
is you know we think that the the
forbrain the part of our brain that
creates strategy Etc is the
supercomputer he said no no no no no
it's like the supercomputer of the brain
is the is the unconscious mind it's the
part of our mind that's controlling most
everything and most people unfortunately
don't do the work to understand how
their unconscious is controlling them
and that's this scary thing this idea
like your mind is controlling you you
you know and I'm not going to get into
the Free Will debate I believe in at
least some
will I believe what you're describing
and this internal
dialogue I think you have access to your
unconscious mind you by listening to the
dialogue going inward we know this is
true in sleep in dreams in meditation
and just by shutting out everything else
shutting out all the external noise
which is filled with things that pull us
to noise makes it sound bad but it's
it's the gravitational full of all the
things that just allow us to distract
ourselves without
knowing that you know the ice cream the
have a cookie the merry
Christmas the unconscious mind this huge
piece of the iceberg underneath that
Paul calls the the supercomputer he's
saying that with knowledge as a
neurobiologist psychiatrist psychologist
he really knows that's the piece that if
one does real introspection he calls it
the cupboards you got to look in the
cupboards and it's often really scary
what you find in there and most people
are just like I don't even want to know
the cupboards are there but you're
pulling all the cupboard doors
open and then you're and I'm you're
extremely deliberate with what gets put
into action you're not just going oh
like I'm pissed so I'm gonna act pissed
or I'm you know tired so I'm GNA act
tired it's you're picking very carefully
what to
do and that's a process that I'm
guessing came to you does it come to you
as a okay it makes sense why running
makes sense it makes sense why why smoke
jumping makes
sense so it seems like a
huge portion of your time is
spent understanding yourself and making
sense to you and so when people don't
understand you it's got to be extra
frustrating yes because most people
don't understand themselves so we're all
running around going like you're this
and you're that because most people are
just unwilling to look Inward and I'm
including myself by the way I mean I've
done a fair amount of introspection but
I'm inspired today that word inspire but
it's true
motivated to start going inward further
cuz it is scary it's like we don't know
what's in those cupboards and it's
terrifying yes especially because we
don't know and those are the first ones
that open up and like he talked about
you gotta go through those cupboards I
do spring clean every day in
those dark cupboards those th those dark
cabinets the ones I start with first
that's the real me
man that's the real me that's why I'm
not
ashamed I don't hide I used to hide I
don't hide anymore he's exactly right I
I don't know all the science
behind I know what I know that's
why I don't listen to anybody anymore I
don't listen to I think most people
are full of because I know I know
the Deep tar secrets of those
cupboards it's ugly man and every day
I'm talking to them every day I'm
cleaning them I'm I'm cleaning them and
I'm talking to the same demons that came
out of those covers as I'm as
I'm cleaning them sometimes they go
right back in them again it's not
easy and this is why most of us just Why
am
misunderstood because what it comes out
of those cabinets that I'm
cleaning sometimes they see on
Instagram sometimes they'll see in the
podcast sometimes they see in this one I
turn people off open up your own
cabinets and then go talk about it let
me see how pretty it looks let me see
how pretty you sound
let me see how put together your words
are I bet you a or a
comes out because for you to go back in
there again to clean the same
cabin that the demon came out of take
some big balls bro to do it every day of
your life to go back in there in spring
clean every day not once a year
once every decade every day you know it
gets dusty and every day you don't start
with the with the
victories you don't go oh this is nice
look at my look at my I love me while
let me clean up this little Dusty no I
go right for the things I G to keep me
buried I go right there first because if
I don't clean those out first the day
doesn't
start so what do you saying to me is
truth and like I told you many times
today I could never figure out how to
explain this to people because I'm
not neuron nothing I'm just a guy that
said okay we got to start in the dungeon
and we got to stay here for the rest of
our lives for you to become successful
the dungeon is a place that has to be
clean and it's the scariest place to be
that's why I'm misunderstood because I'm
speaking from the dungeon that's why I
am
successful because I go there every damn
day and that is the truth what he says
it's the exact truth the those cabinets
are Dusty dirty and scary as
broken
glass
dark spiders
cobwebs but most of all your biggest
fears the biggest things that put you in
the up place you are today are in
there that's why we all like to keep
them shut even like to lock them up act
like they never happen that's why you
never grow you never improve you never
have real conversations like we're
having right now never
never oh no no no no no no let's not no
no no let's not go there I talk to so
many people who tell me
that let's talk about this because
they'll tell me but they can only say it
once and they'll say it in passing they
won't get deep in the weeds with it like
you can't just clean it you
gotta spitshine that you
got to relive it every detail of
it you can't like oh yeah yeah my dad
beat me and you know you know it is what
it is hey it is what it is
it's it's killing you it's taking over
your whole life but that's the
convers yeah my dad I'm fine now though
I'm good okay all right no you ain't you
ain't fine you ain't fine this is this
is real talk people don't to have that
so your boys right 100% right scary as
it's scary as
but makes you who you're supposed to be
and that's the test we forget we we
think we're supposed to breathe air and
have kids and pay the bills and
everybody what what's this life
about that make no
sense being tested my friend tests
come when you have not
studied tests come when you think that
you're in a great place that's that's
the test test the test is every day of
your life and most of us fail because we
don't know why we're here because we
don't go inward to say oh you gave me a
lot of to fix man and this test
sucks but then you
start David
Goggins I don't think I could add to
that I know I
can't thank you for sharing what you
shared today
I
mean as much as your process or anyone's
process can't be completely understood
from the
outside you gave us a real window into
this
thing this process that you was as you
said God put it on you I believe in God
too people can believe what they want
but I somehow your your life God gave
you these challenges early on and then
there was a point where you went
internal and like you said you developed
a skill but it's a perishable skill yep
and you clearly live in the process of
opening those cupboards reopening those
coverboards trying to spit shine those
cupboards understanding that they're
never ever really done but that you can
gain ground on them that you can win day
after day after day and you really
shared a lot of concrete things that I
think I know people are going to be able
to apply if they choose right and I
agree with you I think most people will
be like whoa that was a lot yep it's
heavy I think I want to just kind of
bake myself in Netflix
and check mix yep
instead but there's
also the reality that there are men and
women boys and girls who hear that and
go okay and start cracking the the
cupboards open right and I I just know
that you know for myself I'm extremely
grateful that you're willing to put it
all out there you're so brutally honest
so brutally authentic that word
authenticity gets thrown around so
much and I can tell you that for me and
for everybody else like that's what
really what resonates so whether or not
you want to whether or not it's the
purpose behind it or not you're lighting
the path so
thank you respect thank you thanks for
having me thank you for joining me for
today's discussion with David gogins to
learn more about David and to find links
to his two fantastic books can't hurt me
and never finished please see the show
note captions if you're learning from
and or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zeroc cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and apple and on
both Spotify and apple you can leave us
up to a five-star review please also
check check out the sponsors mentioned
at the beginning and throughout today's
episode that's the best way to support
this podcast if you have questions or
comments about the huberman Lab podcast
or if you have suggestions about guests
or topics that you'd like me to cover
please put those in the comment section
on YouTube I do read all the comments
not on today's episode but on many
previous episodes of The hubman Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep for hormone support and
for Focus if You' like to learn more
about the supplements discussed on the
hubman Lab podcast please go to live
momentus spelled o so that's Liv
mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am huberman lab on
all social media platforms so that's
Instagram Twitter threads X linkton and
Facebook and on all those platforms I
discuss science and science related
tools some of which overlaps with the
content of the hubman Lab podcast but
much of which is distinct from the
content on the hubman Lab podcast so
again it's hubman lab on all social
media platforms if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter I encourage you to do so it
is completely zero cost and it provides
podcast summaries and protocols in the
form of brief PDFs of one to three pages
things like deliberate cold exposure a
protocol for foundational Fitness uh
protocol for deliberate heat exposure
for managing dopamine for optimizing
your sleep and so on and so on again
completely zero cost you simply go to
hubman lab.com go to the menu scroll
down to newsletter and click on the
newsletter Tab and enter your email to
sign up but I should point out that we
do not share your email with anybody
thank you once again for joining me for
today's discussion with the one and only
David gogins and last but certainly not
least thank you for your interest in
science